candidat en passant par le speed chess
ou les title Tuesday
chess.com/events couvre tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base
retrouverz toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
contend du quotidien les bios des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle par
[Musique]
ailleurs
mesdames et
messieurs nous sommes partis je suis en
train d'essayer de d'avoir les bonnes
cames c'est pour ce temps à 960 je vais
essayer de regarder l'emploi du temps
parce que dites-vous bien que la
dernière fois que j'ai regardé il y a de
jours le site web n'était pas à jour
donc on va essayer d'avoir la
bonne
caméra alors me dem il y en a qu'une qui
marche c'est celle-là pour le
moment je crois ah ça fait tout bugger
[Musique]
euh le son
euh
alors est-ce qu'on aurait pas que la cam
de
Levon c'est qu'on est qu'un
cam je crois pas que les parties
commencé j'essaie de voir parce que la
cam 5 on l'a
pas pour le moment je crois qu'on a
qu'une cam qui
marche
ça va
venir C de Lon bon la partie est partie
je vais essayer de voir l'emploi du
temps du tournoi les amis ne bougez
pas parce que comme je disais le site
n'était pas à
jour donc c'est sûr que c'est pas c'est
pas simple
de de vous donner des emplois du temps
quand on ne sait pas quand il y a pas
quand quand ils n'y sont pas est-ce que
est-ce que le site a été mis à
jour ça c'est loin d'être sûr
hein et ben je trouve pas sur leur site
l'emploi du
temps il y a pas de
schedule euh fluff il a le format mais a
il y a pas le il y a pas le le schedule
je
crois je vais
écrire alors c'est un tournoi je crois
ou c'est c'est euh ils ont un budget
absolument faramineux hein je je pense
que c'est un des une des plus grossees
production de l'année il y a un budget à
mon avis absolument colossal pour pour
ce tournoi parce qu'il y a déjà 200000
dollars de prix mais je pense qu'il doit
y avoir pas mal de starting FEI euh ils
ont peut-être l'ambition même de créer
un cycle de championnat du monde ou je
sais pas quoi j'ai pu lire ça à gauche à
droite donc c'est peut-être un truc où
il y a potentiellement des dizaines de
millions d'euros he qui vont être qui
vont être envoyés donc c'est c'est c'est
pour ça qu'il y a des
des mais en fait j'ai pas de caméra qui
marche j'ai rien qui marche mais au-delà
de
ça c'est un truc qui qui qui est
peut-être censé devenir assez
énorme en terme d'argent
évidemment donc là on a on a pas on a et
on a pas la cam on n pas la cam de
firouja je vais essayer de récupérer
tout
ça mais pas en terme de h alors après en
terme de h la difficulté c'est que le
960 c'est un jeu qui n'intéresse
absolument pas le le
public pour une raison assez simple
c'est que c'est comp compqué
normalement et que ça a aucun intérêt
pédagogique B fou G5 apparemment c'est
déjà perdant
déjà pas terrible à cause de tour G4 bon
j'en sais rien c'est compliqué je je
sais même pas
moi-même donc les règles alors les
règles c'est un peu compliqué en gros
c'est les mêmes règles que les
échecs sauf que là par exemple les
blancs auraient le droit de faire petit
rock et de ramener la tour en jeu et les
Noirs pourraient encore faire Gan rock
ce qui mettrait leur roi en C8 leur tour
en D8 ils auraient besoin de de bouger
la dame et le et le
cavalier on dit l'intérêt c'est éviter
les prépas
ouais mais bon
enfin est-ce qu'ils ont je crois qu'ils
ont un peu de temps pour s'imprégner de
la position oui moi en tout cas je
l'avais hier soir je crois déjà et à
noter qu'après ça va là là c'est en
rapide donc là ce que que vous êtes en
train de voir ça n'a il y a aucun
enjeu en fait c'est juste un tournoi qui
dure 2 jours là aujourd'hui et demain
c'est juste pour faire le
seeding mais il y a pas de il y a pas
d'enjeu en fait que tu finisses premier
ou dernier ça ne change absolument rien
et le tournoi en soi commence réellement
il y a même pas une seule personne
éliminée c'est vraiment c'est c'est il y
a vraiment zéro en jeu et et le tournoi
en jeu commencera seulement entre
guillemets dimanche
donc hier soir après c'était peut-être
pas la bonne position qu'il y avait hier
soir honnêtement j'ai vu ça à 1hure du
matin c'est pour savoir qu' va avir les
n rel blancs non parce que après ça va
être des quarts de finale VBC
ok ça en fait c'est comme un c'est comme
un tour de qualification là les deux
premiers jours sauf qu'il y a pas
d'éliminé donc en fait ça te ça va juste
faire le tableau de 1 à
8 c'est c'est juste un temp de jours
pour le seeding donc en fait tu peux
faire 0 sur 8 ça n'a aucun impact en
fait comme les GP2 F1 pas vraient par
que les GP2 F1 quand tu es premier tu as
un avantage sur les autres là c'est
vraiment comme si après de toute façon
tu commençais tous en en rang
quoi alors ne vous inquiétez pas il va y
avoir beaucoup de de de faute dans le
tournoi d'après l'ordi c'est un jeu
auquel on a beaucoup de mal à bien jouer
parce qu'on connaitt parce qu'il y a pas
de théorie en
fait c'est comme les essais libres voilà
exactement ma sœur Jof c'est comme les
essais libre de F1 c'est exactement ça
c'est as de jours d'essai libre et après
tu as tu as le tournoi qui
commence ça t'arrive de jouer au 960 euh
écoute moi j'y a un petit peu joué parce
que je pensais que le jeu était bien
puis ça m'a très très vite saoulé en
fait ça m'a très très vite saoulé d'y
jouer euh pourquoi saouler parce que
c'est encore plus tactique que les
échecs normaux et déjà les échecs
normaux sont très tactiques là c'est
encore plus tactique on arrive vraiment
pas à bien jouer parce que c'est trop
compliqué genre là parle je comprends
pas ce qui se passe sur genre moi je
pensais que c'est 5 gagnés ce qu'a fait
GH et il se trouve que c'est une gaffe
et il se trouve que je suis pas débile
je pensais que fou B3 ici était très
fort
ah il se trouve qu'après tour F7 F pr F7
t pr F7 les noirs sont mieux ah parce
qu'il va récupérer la cale et qu'il a
plus d'activité ok
peut-être moi je trouve ça top pas de
parcœur sur Ouverture mais tu as déjà
joué parce qu'en fait il y a plein de
gens qui me disent que le jeu est
sympa mais c'est systématiquement des
gens qui ont jamais
joué
sur CHC tu as déjà fait des tournois et
tout il y a pas d'AM B3 échec là
ouis moi je trouve que c'est Dame B3
dame E6 tour
F5
ok B on va voir ce que ça donne hein la
position est vraiment compliquée c'est
difficile à expliquer en
fait on comprend rien déjà sur les
parties de niveau non normal ahis mais
là tu peux rien enfin très franchement
c'est pas de la mauvaise volonté hein
c'est juste tactique il y a rien à
comprendre en
fait très très franchement la plupart du
temps les 15 premiers coups il y a rien
à
comprendre j'ai joué chez chez les
amateurs c'est un peu de la loterie
ouais mais même là c'est un peu de la
loterie là en fait regarde aliera il
était complètement
foutu à vrai dire là il il était
vraiment pas enfin foutu il était pas
bien là le coup c'était tour F1 va
savoir pourquoi ah oui parce que dans la
variante du coup il y a pas cavalier E4
mais du coup al resa tout d'un coup il
fait cavalier D6 il se retrouve mieux
euh je sais pas comment dire quoi très
franchement c'est on sait pas trop
pourquoi en fait
[Musique]
c'est personne sait trop pourquoi en
fait c'est que tactique il y a pas de
raison en
fait
en fait c'est tellement pas schématique
qu'on arrive pas du tout à
jouer c'est un jeu compliqué quoi c'est
vraiment un jeu
compliqué on sait pas trop ni pourquoi
ni comment ça c'est ça s'est retourné en
fait c'est vraiment très très tactique
quoi de commenter ça en lumière le
rapport d'un bon joueur aux échecs
classiques cela dit en fait aux échecs
classiques il y a des
raisons au début il faut trouver la
faiblesse de la position après la
stratégie aussi de prendre le sens
mettre son ro à l'abri et bien sûr la
tactique et les finales éche
traditionnel bah là tu vois par exemple
queon a une partie où ça s'est joué que
sur la
tactique bon eux on sait pas trop ce
qu'ils font ils ont joué que deux
coups ils essayent de faire une partie
plus normale mais ils ont joué que deux
coups quoi ok pourquoi pas ceux qu'on
voit à la
cam ils ont joué symétrique au
début et là les noirs sont mieux mais on
sait pas
pourquoi
cavalier D2 prend G2 roi prend G2 dame
G6 roi F3 E4 bon c'est déjà bien pour
les Noirs à cause de ce truc là que
personne n'a
vu mais en fait c'est ça enfin moi c'est
ça qui me pose problème un peu dans ce
jeu c'est
que enin c'est un peu du hasard
quoi
c'estd que là si vous prangez de marches
c'était jamais en contrôle ni pour les
Noirs ni pour les
blancs c'est un peu un jeu d'opportunité
alors après ils jouent hyper bien
attention ils ont des bons plans ou quoi
mais c'est vraiment un jeu d'opportunité
là faut prend g de qui marche c'est une
opportunité
on peut pas
euh faud voir en classique ouais enin
moi pour y avoir beaucoup jouer en fait
tu as tu as la masse de parties qui sont
qui sont un peu comme ça
quoi
et dinglir en carwana alors eux ils ont
fait que des
gaffes au moins c'est facile il a raté
fouprang de une première fois finalement
il l'a
vu et là et ça il se trouve que c'est
mieux au blanc quand même
pourquoi c'est mieux au blanc ça
ah il trouve que maintenant c'est mieux
au noir parce que sur G5 direct il y
avait D5 qui gagne la qualité et il se
trouve que du coup après D5 cavalier
prend F4 puis on prend C4 et D5 les
blancs sont mieux
ouais mais en fait on peut le comprendre
mais en fait enfin voilà on a on a la
raison pour laquelle j'aime pas trop ce
jeu c'est que déjà c'est dur à
comprendre et que les joueurs
l'anticipent pas en fait ça tombe parce
que ça
tombe c'est vraiment tombé parce que
c'est tombé
quoi alors ça a été trouvé hein quand
même par par Abdou fou prang
G2 et alirea alors ça donne quoi
si même il Arve pas ouais non mais même
eu ils peuvent pas ils peuvent pas
contrôler le jeu est vraiment trop
compliqué et Carlsen en fait on n pas vu
sa game
encore il joue contre ah oui non c'est
la game où ils ont joué deux coups ouais
ok en fait c'est pas vraiment qu'on sait
pas calculé c'est qu'on sa'est calculé
quand on peut avoir des coups candidats
et quand
ça peut être
schématique dès que les parties sont
recambolaises qui est plus schématique
comme là on sait plus calculer en fait
on peut plus parce qu'on on peut plus
évaluer les positions donc si on peut
pas évaluer on peut pas calculer en
fait in capable fich pas tout cette
génération l'ordi il serait défoncer
capable en à ce
jeul vous vous rendez pas compte à quel
point on est plus fort
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup plus de coup
candidat ouais mais c'est surtout qu'on
arrive vraiment pas à évaluer les
positions parce que genre la position le
meilleur exemple c'est
celle-là en fait cette position là enin
je là avec enfin regarde ce qu'il a fait
en je avec les noir il fait quand même
dame3 tour F2 fou H4 et donc il joue
avec cavalier F1 parce qu'il doit
vraiment chasser la dame mais là en fait
tu t'attends quand même tu t'attends
quand même là à être beaucoup mieux avec
les Noirs tu t'attends pas à ce que tu
sois quasiment perdant en
fait g c'est c'est carwana contre dingly
Ren c'est c'est deux joueurs du top 5
mondial et du coup lui il a pas compris
qu'fin là c'est une erreur quand même il
passe de plus 08 à moin1 G c'est des
erreurs énormes qu' font mais parce que
tu peux pas
comprendre genre là faut pour H8 direct
une gaffe oui bon ça ça peut que tourc
ce soit meilleur aussi ils en ont
peut-être aussi absolument rien à [__]
ça c'est possible parce que la tour C
c'était quand même plus logique il se
peut aussi qu'ils en ont absolument
RAF cétait pas comme ça quand les échecs
sont
apparus moins quand
même moins quand même
quand tu revois même les livres de Rui
Lopez et tout dans les Espagnols il y
avait quand même une enfin il une vraie
construction de jeu en fait le jeu il
est un peu parfait le placement de
pièces au début il est parfait pour
jouer c'est un
[Musique]
peu sauver le fou son erreur pas sauver
le fou qu' fallait commencer par
cavalier prend B2 mais qui était
illogique parce que ça donnait un pion
en un mais parce que tu dois vraiment
garder le le fou sur les
chiquiers et oui le truc c'est aussi
qu'on est influencé par toutes les
connaissances qu'on a dans le jeu
normal et puis à vrai dire on a très
vite un un billet cognitif que je pense
je suis pas le seul à avoir mais très
rapidement on a absolument plus rien à
faire genre on prend vraiment ça en tout
cas moi ça me le fait quand je joue pour
un truc de
Belin je sais pas comment dire genre en
mode ouais bon c'est du 960 quoi c'est
enfin tu as un peu ce BIA là aussi c'est
peut-être pour ça que tu en as qui
cliquent plus que d'autres tu en as
peut-être qui l'ont plus que d'autres ce
BIA là mais tu as un peu ce B de dire
ouais bon
ok ça existe depuis combien de temps ça
existe depuis longtemps ça a jamais ça a
jamais
pris ça a jamais pris en popularité pour
plein plein plein de
raisons ça ne pose pas les meilleurs en
finale non bah le champion du monde
c'est West lesau
actuellement après onvera pas le fait
que les joueurs sont contents de faire
autre chose que les prépas d'ouverture
avec des parties commencent après 20
coup ce pointl je préfère que les
joueurs soi plus content que les
spectateurs
non mais je sais pas SS sont
spécialement
contents je crois qu'ils sont surtout
contents parce que c'est un des plus
gros budgets un des temp qui a le plus
de budgets de l'année mais je crois que
c'est tout
hein sa si tu donnes au joueurs des
centaines de milliers d'euros pour faire
un truc qui compte pour rien ils sont
contentsin les parti ensuite s long une
fois qu'on commence le Tablon ce sera
des des parties
longues
qu' sont pas plus contents que quand ils
doiv apprendre de la théorie pendant 2
mois ah ben tu peux les faire jouer en
rapide en fait si tu veux qu'ils ai
moins de théorie à apprendre ou en
blitz mais je veux te dire ce truc de
ils sont pas contents d'apprendre la
théorie c'est vrai mais je veux dire
est-ce que tu demandes à bppé s'il est
content d'aller à l'entraînement tous
les matins enfin genre c'est leur métier
quand même à un moment
donné je sais pas comment te dire ils
gagnent plusieurs millions d'euros par
an c'est leur métier prendre de la
théorie ou enfin je sais pas quoi dire
en fait c'est c'est leur métier c'est
pas juste de venir s'asseoir et de jouer
quoi enfin je sais pas tu regardes
Djokovic son métier c'est pas de venir
le matin au tournoi
quoi si tu veux que les gens s'amusent
tu les fais jouer en rapide ou en blitz
c'est point
barre mais là ça va être en long ouais
après le le le tournoi réel va être en
long
la question c'est est-ce que les joueurs
aiment ce format est-ce qu'ils font des
parties fun de chass 960 alors je sais
pas s'ils aiment ou pas en tout cas ce
que je peux dire c'est que de mes amis
il y en a aucun qui ne joue jamais en
960 donc moi en fait je pars du principe
que si les gens ne jouent pas au jeu
même en partie amicale pour s'amuser
c'est qu'ils aiment pas vraiment le
jeu parce qu'en fait ils jouent tous en
blit en rapide et tu les vois tout le
temps Surat en train de clique en blitz
pour s'amuser et tu les vois jamais
jouer en 960 ne serait-ce qu'une partie
donc ça laisse à penser qu'ils sont pas
super fan Vlad en disait du bien alors
Vlad a dit du bien du 960 mais il a
jamais
joué en fait tu as un truc bizarre c'est
que tu as pas mal de gens qui se du bien
du du 960 et même moi je pensais que
c'était
bien mais
euh mais en fait quand les gens ils
jouent ils arrêtent tout de suite d'
jouer en fait tu as plein de gens qui
disent que c'est sympa et tu mais tuas
tu joues de temps en temps et tout non
je joue pas ça m'intéresse pas mais
c'est sympa comme jeu ouais
ok après il y a personne dans les lobby
en 960 ouais mais c'est parce que les
gens aiment pas y jouer je sais pas
comment dire si les gens aiment le jeu
ils vont y
jouer
c'est enfin après on va voir mais même
là tu vois moi je regarde les parties
franchement je les comprends pas et je
je honnêtement je les comprends pas
enfin elles sont un peu ouf hein les
parties
mais je sais pas comment
dire tuas un côté ou alors regarde
plutôt la partie d'Alera ou ouais je
je il y a un truc qui va pas mais
j'arrive pas à
l'expliquer le problème c'est que
spectateur d'échec c'est en grande
partie un plaisir analogique et mémoriel
compar les positions live avec les
schémat de celles qu'on a joué
impossible en son 6 ce qui est empêche
la recréation des schémas je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que tu dis Pen
Mel mais on va voir peut-être que en
partie longue ce sera
sympa peut-être que c'est le fait que ce
soit rapide que c'est pas cool parce
qu'on a pas le temps de se plonger dans
la
position ce n'est pas une idée de Bobby
Fisher de type de jeu alors pas vraiment
c'est une idée qu'il a repris ça
existait déjà
avant mais oui peut-être qu'en partie
classique ce sera plus intéressant
est-ce qu' en parti long toutes les
positions de départ changeront à chaque
partie je sais pas P& ma en fait il y a
même pas le l'emploi du temps du tournoi
sur le
site alors aujourd'hui il y a quatre
parties aujourd'hui il y a quatre
parties ça joue à 13h 14h30 16h et 17h30
donc ça va finir sur les coups de 19h ça
c'est magnifique évidemment ça met
complètement Gucci et demain
malheureusement on a que trois
parties là je commence à comprendre
pourquoi fou est mieux ah bah il a la
paire de fou tout
bêtement
mais pour moi en fait il faudrait
choisir une position de
départ qui est pas trop bordélique en
fait ça devrait pas être 960 ça devrait
être limité à quelques
positions genre tu as une pièce
intervertie ou deux pièces
maximum je pense que les positions pour
que le jeu il soit intéressant faut que
ce soit vraiment un
truc vraiment
léger
grosse gaffe de
Ding il a fait quoi Ding ah il a donné
une pièce en
un ouais ça
arrive pour le moment les joueurs ont
pas donneent pas l'impression de très
bien bien joué de vue des évaluations
quoi qu'il en
soitdatorov il a l'air pas mal là quand
même c'est pe ça ça je crois que c'est
la partie la plus joli ça pour le
coup estce qu'il a trouvé le fou prang
G2 oua il a fait le petit rock comme ça
ça c'était le petit rock il all vers sa
tour
quoi bien c'est un peu bizarre comme cou
il veut partir avec le roi je peux
comprendre
ouais et oui je suis d'accord avec Pen
Mel le truc c'est que ce genre d'attaqu
là je les aurais jamais dans une partie
d'échec et pour une raison X ou Y du
coup ça m'intéresse nettement
moins
c'est vrai qu'il y a un plaisir
analogique aux échecs il a raison je
m'en étais jamais rendu compte dit de
cette
manière-là tu as découvert ça comment
penmel tellement vrai ce que tu as dit
il y a un plaisir
analogique ah c'est marrant j' avais
jamais pensé [__] c'est hyper c'est
tellement intéressant ce que tu as dit
frérot wou tu as dit un truc hyper
intelligent il y a un plaisir analogique
aux
échecs c'est hyper Smart ce que tu as
dit c'est tellement Smart ce que tu as
dit il a dit analogique il a pas dit
analogue
hein
c'est intelligent ce que tu as dit c'est
vrai en fait parce que là c'est une
partie d'attaque et que le fait que les
pièces soient superement bizarrement
placées tuas tuas tu es tu es tu es
moins hype en fait ah tu as régalé
d'avoir découvert
ça
mais alors ça veut dire que peut-être
que si tous les tournois étaient tout le
temps 960 on aurait le même
plaisir c'est vra pour t les sport quand
tu y penses quand tu VO un athlète
performer dans un sport que tu pratiques
tu veux faire pareil ouais non c'est
vrai et puis c'est vrai que tu compares
entre les sportifs qu'ils ont fait dans
un truc et ouais c'est vrai en fait il y
a un plaisir de comparaison
ouais faudrait ou alors faudrait que les
positions de départ ouais restent les
mêmes pendant plusieurs mois voire même
année en
fait
il faudait qu'une seule position de
départ ouais dans ces cas-là peut-être
ce serait cool je suis d'accord avec
toi
si chaque année y avait une seule
position de 960 ça deviendrait plus joué
ouais pour moi clairement en fait genre
si au 1er janvier un peu comme sur les
saisons League of Legends si genre au
1er janvier on décida ben cette année
c'est ça la position ça donnerait
tellement envie de la trayarde en vrai
de vrai tu dirait ouais ok cette année
c'est cette position là on va essayer de
découvrir des trucs ouais carrément en
fait je pense que oui en fait c'est
clair en fait quand tu changes de
position ça devient naze
instantanément c'est que si en fait il y
a une autre position en fait c'est
évidemment le tournoi à zéro intérêt par
contre il c'est tout le temps la même
position sur tout le tournoi mais il
aurait fallu que la position soit
communiqué en avant ce qui est déjà une
présaison mais oui ce serait hype si
c'était une position par an ou une
position tous les 8 mois ou tous les 2
ans après ça se discute mais oui le fait
que ça change de position ça devient
vite
inintéressant après j'ai peur que les
qu'il ait des positions qui s'épuisent
très vite et qui soi pas intéressante à
jouer
aussi mais ils vont théoriser bah c'est
ça qui est intéressant pendant un an tu
théorises de toute façonin même encore
aujourd'hui aux échecs tu trouves des
nouveautés
hein tu retoures sur pr des ordis des du
parcur non mais enfin faut arrêter avec
ça en
fait g dans tous les sports il y a de la
préparation le service les mecs qui
préparent leur service je sais pas
comment dire c'est inhérent aux échecs
le fait que tu doiv apprendre des choses
par cœur c'est dans tous les jeux vidéos
comme ça gen regarde tu joues à League
of Legends on reprend cette idée là tu
es obligé de connaître les sorts les
machins et tout ce qui fait que League
of Legends ça continue évoluer c'est
parce qu'il change les règles tout le
temps mais je dire tu vas pas avoir
masse de théorie à apprendre si tu
changes tous les ans je te rassure
rien qu'aux échecs après après 1000 an
on arrive encore à trouver des
nouveautés de
partout dans tout il y a de la théorie à
prendre après ce qui est pénible aux
échecs c'est que c'est devenu trop trop
trop prédominant en longue he en rapide
moins quand même mais les échecs normaux
il suffit juste de changer la cadence et
tuélimine une grande partie du du
problème et en plus quand tu accélères
la cadence tu rends le jeu plus
populaire aussi au passage donc tu fais
un peu d'une pierre de coup mais
bon en tout cas ça paraît bien pour pour
les Noirs sais quevon il adore jouer au
960 par contre lui c'est un grand
fan et pourquoi il a pas pris la dame
Abdou bah est-ce qu'il y avait mat
non
elle était jamais comestible cette
dame et vous voyez un autre truc c'est
que enfin je sais je l'ai déjà fait une
ou deux fois mais je sais que je peux
pas faire de vidéos YouTube de ces
parties là genre ça intéresse
personne pour déjà avoir fait des vidéos
du championnat du monde de 960 en plus
avait une super belle parttie de saut là
pour le coup qui avait vraiment fait une
partie
magnifique contre mvl en plus mais je
sais que même si tu fais une partie
magnifique de mvl qui gagne ou qui perde
ça ça n'intéresse absolument pas les
gens genre le watch time il est
ridicule tu vois les gens ils voient ils
voient juste la position de départ il
quitent quoi en fait genre en mode ais
bon
ok gen ok c'est du 960
euh c'est
Ciao
position compliqué il fait
quoi il va gagner contre
g mais la salle de jeu je vous ai dit a
énormément d'argent dans ce tournoi
c'est un truc de
ouf le but c'est que ça divertisse pas
que ser tout le temps à quelque chose
ouais en fait c'est ce qu' expliqué P
tout à
l'heure
c'est qu'en fait le fait que tu puisses
pas comparer à des choses que tu as déjà
faites ou que tu as déjà vu tu as pas ce
ce plaisir en fait ça t'enlève une part
de
plaisir il a raison en fait il a il a
bien il a bien trouvé en fait la raison
parce que c'est vrai que moi j'arrivais
pas à comprendre pourquoi avant qu'il ne
l'énonce
is c'est ça le rapport à ton propre
loisir est
inexistante j'ai l'impression que les
échecs actuels favorisent des personnes
qui on une très bonne mémoire
ouais ça favorise aussi les gens qui ont
une très bonne visualisation ça
favorise je sais pas comment te dire
quoi c'est un jeu d'intelligence donc ça
favorise les gens qui sont plus
intelligents quoi quo enin qui ont la
forme les formes d'intelligence
nécessaires pour bien
jouer c'est une intelligence
particulière mais ça favorise les gens
qui ont ce type d'intelligence
là et la mémoire en fait
partie les blancs peuvent pas arnaquer
ce truc les blancs peuvent arnaquer ce
truc je pense mais la tour venir en
C3 non non mais après c'est intéressant
comme tentative on va voir hein
peut-être qu'on va se prendre petit à
petit au
jeu en tout cas c'est la plus belle
partie celle qui est sur la cam de très
loin
Magnus ça fait
nul les tapurs sont quand même meilleurs
que les matres Fed en 960 euh ouais je
crois que le classement mondial serait
sensiblement le même he les échecs de
toute façon en premier lieu c'est t
c'est un jeu de
calcul donc ceux qui calculent mieux
seront toujours plus
forts euh
combien de coup ça se met devenir une
position compar classique ben là par
exemple celle-là elle va jamais le
devenir euh mais il y en a d'autres qui
le sont très vrai très vite devenu genre
la partie de keer contre Magnus
ouais bon ça l' jamais devenu non plus
hein ok ça all est devenu vite fait là
là après 20 coups ça l' est devenu ça ça
pourrait être une partie d'échec normal
euh ça dépend vraiment est parti mais là
de cette position là je pense ouais au
moins 20 coups
hein là il y a une grosse gaff c'est ça
ouais c'est un peu bête de donner le
pion4 mais bon c'est pas une grosse
gaffe quand même ouais si ça donnait
deux
pions
il est partout firou ouais je pense par
contre que c'est sa dernière sortie là
avant avant gros
d'entraînement il va pasre goche en tout
cas mais tu as quand même les principes
stratégiques et la théorie des finales
qui s'appliquent euh
oui et non parce Queen fait le truc
c'est que
oui mais non aussi un pe ouais en
partie mais le truc c'est que tu Vaas
avoir des finales avec des structures de
pion qu'on a jamais donc enfin ouais
c'est en fait les les échecs c'est
vraiment un jeu très schématique hein on
a quand même souvent des choses qui se
ressemblent
donc oui et non à la fois en
fait mais clairement ça fait perdre de
l'importance au final pour ceux qui
aiment pas les Finals je sais que vous
êtes nombreux ça c'est plutôt
cool
ça c'est plutôt
cool c'est même très
cool ceux qui aiment pas les finales
ouais parce qu'en fait les finales
souvent quand elles arrive en plus elles
sont déjà très
déséquilibrées mvl pas éviter
malheureusement non après Maxime
maintenant il souffre un peu du fait
aussi d'être numéro 2 français hein
malheureusement quand les gens invite le
numéro 1 français ils invitent
maintenant al resza tant mieux pour nous
aussi hein mais tant pis pour
Maxime
tant mieux pour nous aussi d'avoir
un un grand joueur de 9 de d'échec pas
de 960 mais
d'échec
en tout cas ça c'est la plus belle
partie hein de
toutes on va voir si c'est la même
position dans la deuxème partie ça va
être intéressant en tout
cas regarde la force en tactique doit
être assez fort en 960 je pense ouais
après comme je vous dis he c'est
vraiment c'est particulier comme jeu
comme on y joue très peu
aussi ce serait pas pareil si le jeu
était beaucoup
joué puisque les les les les les gens
s'y entraîneraient beaucoup plus et et
enfin peut-être qu'il y a des gens qui
sont plus entraînés que d'autres
c'est un peu moi quand quand j'ai joué
par exemple hier au crazyus j'y joue
jamais il a plein de gens qui étaient
plus fort que moi peut-être que si je
j'y joue là pendant 100 he pendant tout
le mois je serai peut-être plus fort que
après
tu penses tu à quel niveau en 960 néant
parce que je m'intéresse enfin j'ai pas
j'ai jamais joué il y a pas de tournoi
ça m'intéresse pas après si le jeu
devient très connu peut-être je
m'entraînerai je ferai des choses j'en
sais rien à l'heure actuelle juste ça
m'intéresserait pas de de l'étudier ou
quoi que ce soit je sais pas trop
comment
dire c'est comme pour le crazyiaous hier
en
fait mon niveau est
néant je crois que ça va gagner he pour
Abdou
satorov
tu débrouilles pas quand j'ai jou en
Arena
960 pas tant que ça ah mais après c'est
qu'il y a pas mal de triche aussi ouais
donc c'est dur à dire à un moment donné
en fait je me suis fait per fermer par
pas mal de gens qui après ont eu des
comptes fermés
donc dur à dire parce que la triche fait
très très mal en 960 en fait si
quelqu'un triche en
960 il a besoin d'encore moins de coups
que qu'aux échecs normaux vous avez vu
qu'onit fait beaucoup plus de
gaffe il prend eu
de
c'est cool l'incorporer du 960 dans son
entraînement je pense
Pasin je sais pas ce qu'il veut sur FPR
de certains pédagogues prétendent ça
développe la créativité
ouais je sais pas qui en fait
mais
les échecs c'est un jeu très schématique
tu as besoin d'apprendre les schémas que
tu
rencontres
souvent pas besoin d'être trop créatif
en fait tu as surtout besoin de bien
maîtriser tes
schémas et d'être en capacité de
ouais d'ajouter un peu de créativité
mais dans
[Musique]
le dans le cas de ce que tu fais là il f
prend le 7 qui va arriver
ouais je sais pas c'est complexe
là une position pour retrouver une
partie classique pas du tout tu aurais
jamais des tours bloqués et une dame
bloquée comme ça j'ai jamais vu une
position similaire dans une partie
classique tu pourrais pas avoir cette
position en partant d'une position
normale tu pourrais pas avoir ça c'est
quasiment
impossible les pièces sont placées trop
bizarrement
encore faudra avoir mal jouer
avant les études par exemple c'est
position complètement irréaliste mais
ouais enfin ouais mais tu comp enfin
ouais tu compares l'incomparable c'est
pas très grave mais peu
importe c'est pas si réaliste que ça
déjà en plus c'est des finales et en
plus c'est surtout pour travailler le
calcul
en partie longue je préfère largement
regarder du 960 perso tu as déjà
regardé mais il va faire tour des H8 je
pense
je sais pas j'ai l'impression que les
blancs sont gagnants moi mais bon j'ai t
j' l'impression que tu fais roisser de
au prochain et qu' y a plus aucun
problème
ça me fascine que les soient mieux là
j'aurais jamais été capable de le
comprendre impossible à comprendre pour
moi les blancs on l'air tellement bien
tu as une pièce de plus et il a quoi il
a que un pion ça c'est incroyable que
les Noirs soient mieux il fait comment
mais ça me ça me fascine ça ok je fais
roi C2 D4 ok je te bouffe tu bouffes je
te bouffe tu bouffes je fais dame
D1 dame F2 ok je fais tour F en fait
j'avais la ligne dame C5 non mais ça
c'est mieux pour les
Noirs ça me fascine ah parce qu'il va
faire cavalier C6 cavalier B4 et fou F6
ouais ça me fait
comment tu veux comprendre ça en fait
mais il va peut-être le faire au hasard
parce que c'était ma variante principale
pour le coup mais en pensant que les
Blancs étaient quasi gagnants et c'est
l'inverse case noir ouais mais bon pour
le voir d'ici que les cas noirs sont
faibles faut être costaud quand
même ça me tabasse que les Noirs soient
gagnants
4 fou
G7 mais évidemment aucun des deux n'a
compris est-ce qu'il y en a un des deux
qui va comprendre ou pas est-ce qu'il y
a un des deux qui va comprendre ça ou
pas vraiment pas facile à comprendre
honnêtement après il peut l'avoir au
hasard
peut peut-être l'avoir au hasard et être
mieux au hasard en fait ça peut mais lev
n'a pas compris du tout non plus sinon
il aurait pas pris en B5 en fait il
aurait fait RER de
direct ça me faccile qu'en fait personne
comprend jamais rien quoi ça me
bute
ça me fracasse et roi E3 il va faire
quoi d prend C4 F prend C4 cavalier D5 F
prend D5 tu reprends
D5 dame C4 il y a dame B2 et ça va faire
mat ok ça ils vont pas le calculer mais
ils vont le
sentir
donc bon on va voir hein s'il trouve ou
s'il trouve pas
hein
plus que de 30 mais c'est vrai on verra
en partie longue hein très franchement
parce qu'en rapide clairement ils ont
vraiment pas le temps c'est trop
compliqué mais on verra en partie longue
si avec plus de temps de calcul il
réussisse
à à mieux jouer parce que c'est vrai que
l'intérêt du tournoi là c'est de tester
le le 960 en longue ça a jamais été fait
au moins c'est
simple la là clairement en terme de
timing c'est trop trop court position
est tellement compliquée comment tu veux
bien jouer ça avec 2 minutes de chaque
côté c'est
impossible P 96.5 de précision bah après
il y a une longue finale aussi hein mais
oui il a très bien joué àira ah bah
voilà ils ont pas compris c'est bien ce
que je disais pas assez de temps le truc
avec des4 ça me paraissait
inconcevable
mais c'est ouais avec si peu de temps cé
impossible mais là c'est bizarre avec
autant de gaffe il a
86,5 contre 89 de précision
c'est toute façon ces trucs de précision
c'est
pas est-ce qu'on peut avoir de foot
casanche non tu peux pas mais n'a pas
compris non plus non il y a aucun des
deux qui a rien compris là mais
impossible à
comprendre parce que là en fait ce qu'il
pense c'est qu'il va y avoir P pr ben
ouais du coup il a refait une gaffe en
fait la variante main elle était pas
possible à trouver c'était pion prend
tour prend F A3 et sur A6 cavalier C3
cavalier D4 il a dû voir ça et il a dû
se dire que les que les Noirs étaient
pas mal là il y a que roi B1 et ça c'est
beaucoup ce qu'il a fait ça paraît
beaucoup mieux que ce que l'ordi
proposé mais du du coup Levon il a pas
compris il a fait k C3 et là il doit
dire qu'il a D4 ça ça a l'air beaucoup
plus fort que le truc qu'il fallait
trouver bah d'ailleurs c'est la
partie ça visuellement ça a l'air plus
fort
mais ça se peut qu'il gagne encore il
peut encore y avoir des gaffes non mais
ouais à voir en partie longue qu'est-ce
que ça va donner sera
intéressant à la fin quelqu'un va gagner
mais personne n'ura compris pourquoi
c'est un peu ça ouais
mais la position était trop
dure on peut pas leur en
[Musique]
vouloir mais je pense que c'est les
noirs qui vont gagner quand même avec
peu de temps la position semble plus
facile à jouer pour les Noirs c'est
plutôt malin ce qu'il a fait
nadierbeck
les blanc les blan surtout une pièce de
plus dans Têt quand ils verront
l'analyse de la relif non mais ils
savent qu'ils font n'importe
quoi en fait en tu tu en 960 tu sais que
tu vas mal
jouer
enson là Levon ouais il a fait une bonne
série mais les
coup les coup sont bien goupillés pour
lui en fait il s'est retrouvé
bien
c'est possible d'avoir la config de base
non c'est pas possible en fait il il
laisse que 959 positions dans le tirage
au sort au
hasard là il y a pas d'AM prend
F5 je crois qu'il a filé un pion en
un
d'Ille ind non je pense qu'il a juste
gaffé c'est un jeu qui est très
éprouvant physiquement ça demande
beaucoup de concentration comme c'est
pas schématique une nouvelle fois et et
du coup il y a plus de
gaffe
là je pense qu'il va jouer dame D3 ça a
l'air
fort la position avec Damero inversé
c'est possible c'est la même chose non
c'est possible c'est pas pas la même
chose à cause des règles du rock un peu
particulières dans le 960 ce sera pas la
même
chose mais ça par par exemple ce serait
hyper
intéressant come on parlait des
positions intéressantes à changer genre
changer la position de la dame et du roi
ça changerait tellement de choses tout
en restant
schématique
cette fois-ci je pense que c'est ça en
est terminé désespoirs
de de nadierbe il a raté son
attaque écoutez c'était une partie assez
marrante donc prochaine partie sera à
14h30 après on va faire une petite pause
pour récupérer toutes nos émotions
ah il tente comme souvent il tente des
des trucs originaux pour arnaquer Nadir
bec il est assez malin même si c'est
mauvais
scientifiquement ça va lui permettre de
décaler son
roi a gagné
ouais
comme ça il y a plus F5 et puis on prend
et tourg8
mat
il y a une partie de mvl une fois comme
ça il y avait eu des soucis sur qui
avait la couleur soners
fait3 le 4 pour lui rendre
l'initiative
possibleb qui tente un peu tout mais T2
cétait bien joué il revient sur la
deuxième rangée avec la tour pour
défendre après comme je disais c'est pas
trop grave là de perdre pour NBEC le ce
truc de placement a vraiment zéro en jeu
donc c'est pas ça ça fait un seeding
mais c'est
pas comme il y a il y a quand même pas
mal de réussite dans dans ce jeu en
rapide en tout cas c'est pas forcément
le plus fort qui terminera
premier bah on avait vu un so il avait
bah il avait été champion du monde ah
mais cette année c'est Naka qui a eu gag
champion du monde et Naka avait mal joué
et l'année d'après so a mal joué Naka a
bien joué ou un truc comme ça c'est
quand même il y a quand même un peu plus
d'aléatoire donc le
c'est pas parce que tu finis 8e que tu
tomberas contre quelqu'un de plus faible
que si tu finis 6e
quoi mais là de nouveau mais là il y a
pas dame prend F5 juste dame prend F5
dame prend B3
encore mais il y a pas de mat après t
dame pr à3 moi je partirai pour dame pr
F5 mais il doit y avoir un
problème dame pr F5 tour pr F5 et tour
prend A3 tour prend A3 et E2 c'est joli
ça
mais même là ça continue à pas être
clair c'est vraiment bizarre ce jeu ça
me
fascine même cette finale tu l'auras
jamais aux échecs normaux genre ça c'est
égal
ok complètement au hasard ça Tom
bien joué de la part
d'AB
incroyable
lesevon il va être
dégoûté c'est un peu ça le charme de ce
jeu en
fait c'est que tu as des trucs comme ça
qui tombe qui doivent pas tomber et qui
tombe et là maintenant c'est gagnant
pour les Noirs après t reprends à 3 mais
c'est pas trouver là il a prend des deux
seul coup ah non RO1 marche
aussi il il comprend le danger ils vont
faire nul comment il a pas perdu ça mais
c'est bizarre en fait comme les
positions sont jamais vraiment stabilisé
qu' a toujours des trucs
bizarres je vous assure que ça arrive
souvent des retournements de situation
rocambolesque
ça arrive beaucoup plus souvent que vous
l'imaginez faut faire attention de pas
se faire mater quand
même
c'est pas un SIG gros choc en vrai non
c'est pas un SIG gros
choc pour moi c'est pas un si gros de
choc la position était pas facile elle
était pas stabilisée il y avait peu de
temps c'est pour ça que je disais ce
serait intéressant de voir en partie
longue s'il réussisse à
stabiliser des retournements de
situation important sont vraiment
monnaie
courante
be qui va essayer de la jouer le plus
longtemps possible bon ça ça va faire
nul il y avait un bel avantage ouais on
peut on peut un tout petit pe revenir
parce que là il va plus rien avoir
d'intéressant non non mais il était
vraiment complètement gagnant il a
vraiment bien joué et là c'est peut-être
ce F5 qui était mauvais et mais encore
une fois la position était pas vraiment
schématique c'est pas un genre de
position qu'on a souvent et tout d'un
coup cette position c'est que plus 1 8
hein avec tour G1 les trois pions
étaient vraiment très fort au
centre donc c'est vraiment F5 là qui a
était une grosse gaffe il aurait dû
commencer par tour F1 mais c'est
vraiment une grosse gaffe F5 pour le
coup mais c'était pas censé si mal
tourner
hein bon là la partie va durer 50 coups
mais normalement il y aura pas de
mat après chapeau à qui a bien
défendu et oui les deux positions les
deux joueurs on une position symétrique
au au début de la partie voonà ça va
faire nul ça va durer
encore un petit
moment
la finale roi cavalier roi tour elle est
pas très Durre à défendre vous allez
voir faut vraiment mettre la tour
derrière
la partie Ding a été regardé ouais il y
a une énorme gaffe mais était bizarre
cette partie en fait on les a toutes
regardé
hein
ok bon on attend qu'il fasse nul hein
après on aura une petite pause d'un
quart
d'heure
qui essaie de faire des progrès après il
faut il a raison à Levon d'être
vigilant il a raison d'être vigilant
Lvon donc là on est retombé dans une
position qu'on pourra avoir dans une
partie normale pour le coup comme vous
demandiez
comme vous m'aviez
demandé certain jouer d'un côté qure de
l'autre alors quand tu as le le tour
cavalier c'est pas pénible he tu essayes
de faire des progrès c'est marrant par
contre avec la tour c'est un peu chiant
ouais je te confirme tu es pas ravi de
jouer
ça tu es pas complètement ravi
là sur tour H2 il veut tour A2 tour 2
pardon je pense qu'il va faire de RO
F2 mais ça peut durer
là
parce que 25 + 10 ils vont la jouer
pendant 50
coups je pense que ça va faire prendre
un peu de retard c'est pas du long alors
ça va être du long thodor là c'est le
les deux premiers jours c'est deux jours
qui comptent pour du beurre en fait
grosso modo et c'est en rapide et après
c'est les choses sérieuses qui
attaquent là c'est juste pour pour
s'échauffer quoi je sais pas comment
dire et après ça va être des parties
longues bon il défend bien il bloque il
empêche d'être mis sur sur la dernière
rangée c'est pas si simple à faire
donc c'est plutôt très bien réalisé pour
le moment
c'est plutôt très très bien réalisé pour
le
moment qui a défendu ça la B C ouais ben
normalement tu es censé le défendre hein
moi j'ai déjà eu à le défendre j'ai
défendu aussi mais faut faire attention
hein c'est un peu chiant he
réellement là je demande s'il va faire
roi F3 ou juste 3
G2 c'est quoi danger si ton roi se fait
mettre sur la bande après tu peux te
faire matterer quoi grosso
modo là il essaie d'un peu tournicoter
avec le
cavalier après la position de départ
était vraiment bonne
pour pour les
blancs
parement il réussi à rester sur la
deuxième donc ça va mais
attention
terrible mais tu penses qu' c'est normal
de jouer cette nuloric ah moi je la
jouerai non tout le monde la joue hein
non non c'est normal tu as tu as quand
même un ou 2 % de chance de la gagner
regarde les von il su un peu
hein
mais là en fait il faudrait qu'il
réussisse à avir le cavalier en D4 et le
roi en
D3 et ça ça deviendrait un
problème ce qu'il va essayer de faire en
fait gagner encore une colonne et après
ce sera
mat
ça là ça il est rentré dans la zone
dangereuse
hein il est rentré dans la zone
dangereuse mais bon il va peut-être
avoir du Tour B2 pour pour se dégager un
peu de
là il reste combien de
coups bonne
question on prend H7 c'était le 63e il
en reste
encore quinzaine
donc je pense pas que ça reprenne à
14h30 he je vais me faire une petite
pause les voir 550 m non c'est un truc
un peu bizarre tu dois réclamer mais
comme tu as pas de feuille de partie
c'est pas facile enfin bon vous verrez
s'il est proche de se faire mater il
réclamera généralement quand ces cas-là
tu joues tu joues tu joues et si tu as
un coup de mat tu demanderas avec des 50
coups donc la partie peut durer 70 75
coups
je crois qu'ils ont fini par faire
nul NBE a d décider que toute façon il
arriverait pas dans les 50 coups et que
à ce moment-l Levon demandera au dernier
moment donc il a pas voulu reperdre plus
de temps bon écoutez c'était bien sympa
cette cette première
partie on va faire une petite pause je
pense pas que ça reprenne à 30 donc va
on va reprendre à 35 tant que j'ai le
temps moi aussi de de manger un petit
truc
si tu te fais manquer tuas encore le dro
de demander non faut demander un coup
avant de se faire matterer le coup avant
le coup avant que le me te mette tche
quand tu joues tu demandes thodor allez
on va faire une petite une petite pause
et on revient dans une petite dizaine de
[Musique]
minutes
les amis ça va ça va reprendre
euh ça va reprendre on a rien raté hein
entre
guillemets et donc on a toujours en fait
on a chiqué de Levon et les autres
caméras ne fonctionnent
pas ça peut bugger je vais retenter d'en
relancer une ça peut
buggerading qui en a absolument rien à
faire il a gaffé et complètement
endormi
be Ding mais il y a Ker en
face est-ce que ça va être la même
position ou une autre j'en sais rien ah
ça y est ça a commencé désolé alors il
ça ça a
commencé j'y comprends
rien euh parce qu'on a ça qui a commencé
mais je pense que c'est juste qu'ils ont
bougé les pièces ah ils ont on changé la
position de départ je
crois et ils discutent de la position de
départ là entre
eux c'est pour ça que les échiquers
bougent donc on a la réponse hein ce
seront des positions de départ
différentes à chaque partie
apparemment excellent comme ça on va
voir des des positions différentes ça va
vraiment être passionnant
il ouais je pense qu'un gars qui a les
blancs analyse avec un gars qui a les
Noirs bah super après le tour va avoir
un peu de retard ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour moi aussi donc il y a que
des que des bonnes
nouvelles
on va attendre on verra bien le ce qui
ce qui joue on
observera en tout cas c'est bien il y a
des belles pauses et ça ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir bien
évidemment donc ça veut dire qu'on va
être ensemble ce soir à mon
avis
jusqu'à 19 voire même 20h ça va faire
une belle
journée combien de parties aujourd'hui
qure parties aujourd'hui
exceptionnel
exceptionnel ça sera la position de
départ ça commence à ça devait commencer
à 14h30 donc il y a un peu de retard
c'est pas très
grave
on discute avant je sais pas à quelle
heure ils vont
reprendre sympa en tout cas de les voir
parler comme ça
on sent que moi ça me fait super PLA que
ce soit en retard ouais je te le dis
très franchement je suis vraiment très
heureux
allez on a on a la caméra sur abdousatov
contre Ding on va un petit peu regarder
ça au
début joue pas le fr si si joue àa mais
on a je sais pas pourquoi la caméra Lode
pas je vais réessayer de Loder des
caméas ça peut tout faire bugger
attention à chaque
fois en fait j'en ai deux qui marchent
là
maintenant ah bah voilà ça y est je
l'ai je l'ai on a celle d'aliira B on va
regarder
alirea allez on va mettre la partie
d'alierza il est où il est là
magnifique c'est le seul entre ton
amateur et ton ao le retard systématique
ouais 20 minutes de retard quand même he
c'est pas rienin mais
euh alors par contre il y a un bug sur
l'affichage alors il y a un bug
d'affichage par
contre voilà c'est bon c'est
réglé
magnifique
ok bon ça se développe on va voir
l'ouverture ça joue au centre les pièces
sont plutôt placées pour jouer au centre
ça donner peut-être des positions plus
normales que la position
précédente
ça attaque le pion central donc il doit
réfléchir à D6 F6 cavalier G6 il y a
plein de coups he pour
défendre al la position de départ c'est
pas la bonne
là-bas je vais voir si je
peux probement je vais l'enlever ça
semble pas fonctionner donc il a joué C6
il défend le
pion il a gagné contre g mais
après
là ça ça vraiment pas d'en jeu du tout
hein mais il doit y avoir moins de moins
de nul dans ce dans ce format boom
patatra
il joue pour se chauffer là
ouais les joueurs vont toucher de la
caillass quand même alors je sais pas si
sur le rapide il touche de la caillass
mais ce que je peux te dire c'est vu le
nombre de
tweets et vu l'engouement des joueurs
pour ce truc là ils doivent toucher
énormément d'argent et quand je dis
énormément d'argent ça doit être
irréel le rock n'existe pas si tu verras
quand ils vont rocker si tu restes un
petit peu tu vas voir le petit rock et
le grand rock comment ça se
passe en gros il va le roi va venir en
G8 et la tour en F8 et là s'il fait
grand rock la tour viendra en D8 tu
verras quand quand ça pourra se passer
je te ferai signe si tu es toujours là
dis-moi c'est une avancétion de faire
des matchs de ce niveau sur ce mode de
jeu euh
ouais une innovation oui une avancée je
crois pas mais une innovation oui en
partie longue en tout cas ça a jamais
été fait en fait tous les tournois de 96
qui
existe ont été arrêtés parce qu'à chaque
fois c'est des bides monumentaux ça
n'intéresse pas les gens en
fait mais ça n'a jamais été fait en
partie longue ça n'a été fait que en
rapide donc je pense qu'ils espèrent que
le 960 en longue soit plus intéressant
pour le public on verra
si si le public est au rendez-vous
hein
donc il000 fou en B3 ok on va voir il y
a tout un tas de coup il peut prendre il
peut jouer fou e 6 il peut jouer
cavalier E6 pas simple he comme position
mais c'est
plus la position est plus normale et
plus schématique que la
dernière
Jer k
G6 ok G3 bloque le
cavalier je pense c'est intéressant si
on explique avant les enjeux de la
position de départ bah on les connaît
pas en fait hein position de départ elle
arrive le jeu est trop compliqué en fait
on sait pas comme tu vois les joueurs
eux-mêmes font que des
erreurs donc on sait pas non plus quels
sont les enjeux c'est compliqué en
fait on sait pas en fait on regarde
juste il y a plein de coup possibles
mais les enjeux c'est dur de comprendre
he c'est toujours un peu la même chose
façon prendre le centre euh machin
mais en fait tu vois bien que les
joueurs jouent eux-mêmes très
mal question qu'on peut se poser c'est
ce que s plus intéressant que le
classique en longue du point de vue des
joueurs peut-être le fait qu'il ait
moins de préparation on le fera plus
agréable pour les joueurs a mais
enfin ça c'est un truc que j'arrive
jamais à comprendre
trop en fait les mecs ils sont payés des
des millions d'euros en fait tous les
ans s'il y a pas de public pour regarder
ce qui les intéresse les joueurs c'est
l'argent en fait hein enfin je sais pas
vous vous êtes un peu bizarre les amis
du point de vue des joueurs je pense que
les joueurs de foot ils préféraent qu'un
mi-temps il dure 30 secondes hein il
prendrai 200 million par an ou 200
millions par an à jouer une minute de
foot toutes les semaines il serait
content aussi enfin pas comment dire il
se trouve que les joueurs ne jouent pas
au 960 en partie amicale
jamais donc si ça les intéresser autant
et que ça les a muté autant tu les
verrais tout le temps jouer en 960 j'ai
cet argument de dire que les joueurs
ador alors qu'ils y jouent pas une
seconde de leur vie ça me ça me fascine
en fait à chaque
fois non mais c'est qu'à niveauur on
s'ennuie je pense voir Fabiano tir 25
coups de prépa
ouais enfin moi aussi mais je enfin
c'est c'est les échecs modern qui sont
comme ça mais comme je disais tu les
fais jouer en rapide ou en blit et tu as
plus la
prépa mais est-ce qu'il joue pas
justement parce qu'il y a rien à gagner
aujourd'hui mais il jouent pas parce que
personne n'a envie d'y jouer en fait je
sais pas comment t'expliquer
s'il y avit beaucoup d'argent ils vont
se mettre à y jouer parce qu'il y aura
beaucoup d'argent mais je veux
dire les gens quand ils veulent s'amuser
et jouer aux échecs ils font des Blitz
ou des
rapides mais je sais pas s'il préfère le
le classique un boom patatra je pense
qu'il s'en fiche globalement je pense
que les joueurs ils préfèrent le truc
ou il préfèrent le jeu a le plus de
public pour gagner le plus d'argent en
fait
globalement c'est ça qu'il faut se
dire à quelque chose près et les
classiques ils aiment bien parce que
c'est la tradition et du coup tuas un
peu on est d'accord que les Blancs ont
un avantage certain comparativement au
normal bah là tu vois que les noirs sont
mieux alors on sait pas trop pourquoi
mais je pense c'est à cause du Fou G1
qui est mal
placé tu penses réement qu'il n'y a
aucun plaisir pour
eux c'est pas qu'il y a aucun plaisir
mais c'est un métier en
fait c'est vraiment l'argent la première
motivation mais c'est normal
hein il y a vraiment pas de mal à ça en
vrai je vois pas pourquoi ça devrait
être tabou les gens jouent que pour
l'argent en fait ils sont enfin il
passerai pas leur vie à faire çaain hein
ils s'en foutent
hein il y a un peu un mythe des sportifs
qui adorent pratiquer leur sport qui
existe il préfère faire ça autre chose
hein attention mais en soi
euh les gens jouent pour le World Title
en échec en vrai oui mais c'est une
nouvelle fois c'est pour la gloire
l'argent mais c'est normal c'est c'est
parce que ça devient un métier c'est
c'est tu vois genre Fab et Maé quand il
veulent s'amuser ils jouent au tennis
mais je pense que Djokovic il s'amuse
plus en jouant aux échecs je sais pas
comment
dire du coup il pourrait faire n'importe
quoi d'autre mais je pense qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui aimeraient faire autre
chose moisette mais juste c'est ce qui
leur apporte nêtement plus d'argent que
le reste c'est pour ça qu'il continue
mais c'est normal il ça va pas être
tabou en
fait on s'habitue on se lasse de tout
exactement JSC
mars le public a pas trop envie de voir
que des coups a pris par cœur aussi bah
il y a toujours beaucoup plus de public
quand tu regardes des échecs classiques
que du 960 mais c'est enfin c'est pas
c'est pas grave le 960 c'est trop dur en
fait comme
jeu le jeu est vraiment dur et tu peux
pas reproduire ce que tu vois dans les
parties tu apprprends absolument rien en
les regardant donc c'est en fait tuas un
double problème mais c'est pas c'est pas
grave mais c'est pour ça que les gens
aiment autant regarder le rapide et le
Blitz genre vous avez vu bah on a
regardé le champion ch tour qui s'est
terminé avanthier ça s'est jamais joué
dans l'ouverture au contraire c'était
même plutôt sympa la partie où il y
avait une grosse prép tiens là tu vois
le petit
rock c'était même plutôt sympa l'énorme
prépa qu'il avait eu dans la première
partie du match entre Carlsen et
firou les prépa quand elle dur 25 coup
ce qui est chiant c'est qu'il m
longtemps à les jouer c'est pas le fait
qu'elle du 25
coups le fois je tire une salale tranche
ouais
ils ont en temps de préparer les
positions je crois qu'ils ont un petit
quart d'heure he ce qu'on les a vu on
les a vu s'entraîner donc je dirais un
quart d'heure
ouais al là les blancs vont être mal
parce que ce fou est horrible pour alier
en
H2 c'est kata pour
Aliza il a raté
l'ouverture peut pas pousser G4 G4 c'est
trop compromettant pour le
roi
bon on va voir comment ça se ça se
passe
C tu en as pensé quoi euh je suis pas
fan du crazyus
après j'avais pas mal joué plus jeune
mais le jeu est marrant mais bon pas
fan mon ma variante préférée c'est le
King of the hill parce que ça ressemble
vraiment beaucoup aux échecs pour la
peine mais ça rajoute juste une toute
petite règle qui est qui est sympa pour
ça que j'aime
bien tu es pas complètement perdu et tu
as un objectif de tu as une win
condition différente donc c'est c'est
c'est sympa ça rajoute une deuxième
manière de gagner c'est assez
drôle mais peut-être que si on y jouait
beaucoup ce serait naz
hein le Stre check c'est assez marrant
aussi ouais parce que les règles sont
faciles à comprendre mais
euh mais c'est très difficile à
jouer je pense pas que des parties plus
rapides auraient été mieux bah là en
fait ils sont rapides French baguette
après ça ils vont passer en partie
longue
an VO être mal à cause du fou on va voir
s'il s'en sort
he
ils vont toujours entrer en rapide plus
en longue alors en rapide ils vont juste
faire un tournoi de placement c'est ce
que tu es en train de
regarder
et après une fois que ce tour sera fini
le premier contre le 8e et cetera il
feront un tableau en partie
longue et le ho n'est pas spécifique
non connaissant la f on parî combien qu'
vont se dire c'est la M d'or ce truc et
changer for cycle mondial pour jouer en
960 non je pense qu'il vont essayer de
faire un deuxième cycle potentiellement
il y a forcément un mec m qui a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent qui met de l'argent pour faire
ce tournoi
et donc forcément tous les joueurs vont
lui dire que c'est génial enfin truc
typique des
échecs et que c'est l'avenir du jeu
et tout le monde va essayer de prendre
plein de fric
quoi typique de ce qu'on voit dans les
échecs
fréquemment
possible que Magnus soit pas champion du
monde en 960 bah écoute à chaque fois
qu'il a participé il a pas gagné
Magnus mais comme je dis c'est un jeu
pas très schématique donc c'est un peu
particulier
le F H2 est vraiment l'IT mais
bon sympa comme syème de touris c'est
pas mal tu as de deux jours de rapide un
peu pour s'échauffer après tu as le tu
as le vrai tournoi qui
commence ça manque de pub ouais tout les
Prem temps je F ça onetouré leur vest
c'est dire que c'est beaucoup mieux le
960 alors après le le speedcha savait
introduit dans un moment des parties de
960 au début des
segments et du fait que ça intéressait
personne ça avait été arrêté en fait
toutes les expériences à chaque fois
avec ce jeu elles sont arrêté parce que
ça oua toujours pour la même raison en
fait le truc voyez c'est que là
physiquement c'est une position que vous
ne pourrez jamais avoir aux échecs un
fou ne peut pas être enfermé derrière
des pions comme ça c'est juste pas
possible en fait il faudrait que le fou
soit venu en F4 parti en H2 qu'on a joué
G3 et repris en F4 en gros vous allez
jamais avoir une position comme
ça après ça reste intéressant de voir
comment il va
l'exploiter
il a pas l'air bien là lirea
après
rien de dramatique on va voir s'il
réussi à la
tenir mais un autre désavantage c'est
que ce sera un un autre avantage c'est
que ce sera pas possible de faire nul
avec les blancs en fermant le
jeu
ok D F6 un plan ouais il y a plein de
plans làin le kg8 F6 oui bah il est
vraiment très bien et son avantage est
très
durable
pas mis à jour la position de départ
malheureusement je voulais vous la
mettre mais elle elle a pas été mise à
jour
ouais F6 je sais pas ça paraît quasiment
injouable pour pour les blancs je pense
qu'il va vouloir donner sa tour dans de
bonnes condition et reprendre de F pour
réactiver le fou on va
voir
pr mis paquet sur de caméra ouais ah
ouais ils ont un c'est sûr qu'ils ont un
budget colossal pour ce
tournoi
B caméra ouais la caméra de dessous
c'est
sympa tu manger les VI de la 7 la 2è à
la 7e rangée
ouais ce serait pas
mal
qui charbonne he quand même ce mois-ci
entre VI le champion chest tour et et ce
tournoi il joue
beaucoup mais c'est
bien il en avait
besoin
1200 € pour le denue au resort officiel
du Tour mais je crois que c'est un
resort où il y a eu des où il y a des
gens très riches qui
vont
je crois que ça a lieu dans un endroit
pour pour les gens vraiment ultra ultra
ultra
blindé
en tout cas la production est vraiment
au niveau hein 5 il y a quatre
caméras par chiquier je
pense j'ai une question à position de
base et la même sur mais du coup ils
peuvent se lever aller voir ce ce que
joue un mec ouais c'est pas une bonne
idée c'est de faire ça ils peuvent mais
c'est ça ce serait pas
rentable
que comm sur l'organisation est pas du
tout
hein
alle les noir là vont mettre la pression
petit à
petit ça a l'air
inexorable
là il se barre avec le roi ça jouit
alors qu'ils ont le temps ouais parce
que c'est du jeu de placement il peut
rien se passer de gravissime en un coup
là
pas de plan clair pour pour carwana non
pas de plan
clair les autes parties si tu
veux al ça on une finale complètement
normal mais avec un pion de plus donc ça
plus d'
qui va être à zé sur de je crois qu' en
a vraiment rien à faire c'est magnifique
ça une position qui est pas complètement
normal mais qui va être quand même plus
schématique c'est mieux pour les
blancs et là on a aussi une position
bizarre Magnus qui a l'air bien
il a fait ça
comment g sens que c'est bien joué je
crois
son roi l'air faible ouais c'est le
problème
alors disun égal maintenant pour aller
il va pouvoir tout
bloquer
il y en a qui va faire une forteresse
ouais pour maintenir la pression ouais
je pense que c'était il fallait jouer
très
précisément là l'ordi voulait faire dame
D7 ouais je sais pas en fait il voulait
surtout pas faire B5 je
crois parce que il y a plus de rupture
avec
A5
hâte de voir en partie longue en tout
cas ce que ça va
donner
impatient
ça donne vraiment l'impression d'être
gagnant pour les Noirs mais ça l'
pas est que tu dis que tu pouris ramener
ta dame en D6 ton cavalier en E6 c'est
ce qui fait
ouais mais ça va tenir de justesse à
chaque
fois
d en D2 plutôt mais je voulais dire avec
la même
idée ENF pas on la mettra EN3
mais ça a l'air d'être une forteresse
étonnant mais pas assez de faiblesse il
va la jouer ça peut quand même craquer
je vois la perdre carwana je pense pas
qu'il puisse la perdre je vois pas
comment les blancs peuvent gagner mais
il va tourner tourner tourner peut-être
il sacrifiera un jour et il finira même
par perdre bon on va voir he de toute
façon
je pasure ils ont rien à faire euh
euh bah après là il joue ni leur hello
ni le ni quoi que ce soit en
fait on peut pas leur envo leur
envouloir Arthur
tur là il joue même pas en fait là il
joue rien en
fait
les seeding ouais mais seeding ça change
vraiment rien du tout
là
ils réussiront pas à passer hein c'est
une
forteresse il va peut-être essayer de
jouer à 5 en ramenant le fou en C7 et
cetera
hein
B il y a pas grand chose à dire pour le
moment il se passe rien dans cette
partie on va
voir une forma longue non c'est forat
longue ce sera deux parties ce sera
aller
retours ça va être assez extraordinaire
ça aussi ça va être vraiment magnifique
il faudra ne pas rater
hein il ne faudra surtout pas
rater ça ça commence dimanche le quart
de finale dimanche lundi après mardi
mercredi et jeudi vendredi la
finale faudra surtout surtout surtout
pas
rater
elle va peut-être finir par passer hein
c'est
possible
il double he il essaie de passer on va
voir s'il y arrive ou pas il va faire
fou C7 il va forcer à 5 mais est que ça
va
suffire
F3 jour c'est possible non tu veux
vraiment
pas tu veux plus toucher à rien
là-bas le pion côté al en G5 c'est pas
possible non il a pas le droit des pions
F4 et euh et H4 ont pas le droit d'aller
vers la case
G5 faudrait qu'il mange quelque
chose
je vi revoir ton fir d'hier il est
pépite ça m fait beaucoup de bien merci
pour ce moment ah c'était drôle
hein qui va jouer le pion avec A5 ouais
c'est
logique
est-ce que ça Perm commenter ces
événements ça va écoute
hein ça
passe mais heureusement parce que
sinon ah c'est quand même il commence à
menacer cavalier E3
cet événement là il est dur celui-là il
est vraiment dur
et ce tournoi sur invitation ouais c'est
sur invitation et c'est juste un tournoi
poon ouais c'est que pour la cayass
là listrat tu a pris ou là non ça va
finir tard
après je vais aller dormir là il y a
encore 6h de jeu demain là ça va jouer
tous les jours pendant 6h he là je vais
récupérer à fond
hein
combien de car en jeu alors
officiellement il y a 200000 dollars de
prix mais vu les tweets et vu tout je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de de starting
fee je pense qu'il y a au moins alors
après je peux pas savoir hein mais de
mon estimation il y a au moins 600 ou
700000 € rien que pour les joueurs de
mon estimation
personnelle
m voulait pas de Kas pas invité ben pas
invité là il y serait allé c'est de la
cayas gratuite pour un truc qui sert à
rien ça compte pas pour lesé lot ça
compte pour rien c'est
magnifique là pour les joueurs le
tournoi il est exceptionnel il y a
énormément d'argent pour un truc qui a
aucun
enjeu et où il y a même aucun risque il
y a pas d'élo il y a rien il y a même
pas de prépa à
perdre bizarre de pas l'inviter non
c'est normal hein ils invitent les tout
meilleur Maxime il est plus trop dans ce
cercle en ce
moment bah le tournoi là pour les
joueurs il est vraiment
idéal
bah ils ont invité qui ils ont invité
mon Carlsen carwana
Ding déjà ça fait vraiment énormément de
sens après ils ont quoi firouja CER
c'est le local de l'étape Levon parce
que Levon c'est un des plus grands fans
de 960 donc ils sont dit qu'ils allaient
l'inviter Goh public indien c'est normal
et il m'en manque un
non il manque un camura mais qui a pas
dû vouloir venir parce qu'il y a les
candidat bientôt il veut pas peut-être
enfin il est déjà blindé de fric il a
peut-être pas envie de perdre son temps
avec
ça et j'ai pas dit abdous satorov je
croyais l'avoir dit mais du coup il a
abdous satorov qui a été champion du
monde de
rapide et qui est un des jeunes qui
monent fort
aussi c'était logique de pas inviter un
deuxème français après j'imagine qu'ils
auraient préférer avoir Nakamura à la
place d'abdous satorov par exemple mais
en soix en soit le choix d'abdous
satorov et
relativement logique quand même je pense
que leur premier choix c'était plutôt
nepo ou ikarou ou
quoi
après NPO ils onont peut-être pas invité
parce qu'il est russe aussi je sais pas
tu as des tu as des tournois comme le
tournois en Norvège ou quoi qui veulent
pas inviter de
russe pourquoi légè avantage ben parce
que c'est les noirs qui ont toutes les
poussées partout et qui ont toute la
pression partout sur les
Chiquet
en soit il manque les deux derniers
champions du monde de 960 ikarou et sa
quoi qu'il en
soit
en soit il manque quand même les deux
derniers champions du monde de du
jeu et F3 non F3 c'est vraiment jamais
un coup F3 serait la pire idée tu ferais
que
t'affaiblir touvrira une colonne en plus
pour les tours adverses ce serait
vraiment pas
bien
en tout cas on voit vraiment une très
belle partie
là
ça se fait d'abandonner par flemme
surtout s'il y a pas d'enjeu non
je crois qu'il veut réussir à jouer à 5
au final
mais fa regarder avec une grosse survine
mais en vrai on s'en fiche un peu on
aura jamais la position dans une partie
réelle donc on s'en fiche en
fait cette position mathématiquement tu
pourras jamais l'avoir
donc on s'en fiche un peu d'avoir le
plan de gain mais c'est sûr qu'il joue
avec
A5
oui en fait la position elle est
vraiment impossible à
avoir
après que sur les plans peu importe la
position ça peut faire progresser pour
les idées bah de toute façon c'est sûr
qu'il veut jouer pour A5 mais après
pourquoi est-ce que les noirs sont si
mieux est-ce que ça suffit pour gagner
ça j'en sais rien mais ça peut être que
à 5 le plan en
fait il y a pas d'autres points d'entrée
donc il y a même pas de question à se
poser mais après pourquoi est-ce que
c'est autant
mieux je sais pas moi je pense qu'il va
gagner avec les Noirs quand
même
fou 3 est trop
horrible
HM ok je regardais des images du
tournoi
il veutue à bloquer avec Dame B3 et tout
est changé c'est pas bête he ce que
faitza ce n'est pas
bête même plutôt assez
malin mais bon avec ce fou en
G3 à mon mon avis ça doit finir par
craquer on va voir hein si
si ça
réussit côté
noir on va
voir
si change de dame c'est nul ça dépend où
et
comment mais tu AAS quand même des
chances de gain même sans les dames le
pion C3 peut se retrouver à être
sensible
heureusement qu'Ali est bien autant
ouais c'est ce qui va peut-être le Sauer
le
sauver
il arrive pas à percer le problème c'est
qu'il peut se faire contrer aussi un
carwana il s foutu mal aut temp c'est
très étonnant mais il peut se retrouver
par se faire contrer même alors qu'il
voulait sûrement avoir une position où
il avait zé chance de perdre
bon il reste plus 10 minutes maintenant
alirea
on peut ramasser B5 puis D5
ouais
c'est ce qu'il va faire après le Fou est
tellement mauvais
que mais il est même capable de la
perdre Fabiano c'est terrible quand
même
c'est quand même
terrible
h
r j'ai de bon non mais ça ça ça va faire
nul
hein
mais il va même se retrouver mieux
ouais bon il va pas gagner quand même
parce que le fou peut pas participer
mais là maintenant on peut même penser à
faire F3 c'est quoi ce coup d'am8 c'est
plutôt bien
joué mais là ça y a lera qui a
complètement
égalisé il va garder les dames et ils
vont faire
nul ils vont faire une petite nuulle bon
c'est une partie qui aura pas été
grandiose hein mais c'est comme
ça
for l'ouverture mais' a bien tenu ouais
après
exactement
le fois fait son taf défensif ouais là
ils vont faire
nul bien tenu par Alireza
comme je disais je suis curieux de voir
la même chose en partie longue quand
même on va on va voir ce que ça
donne
bon ça toujours pas répété mais ça va
répéter
et voilà ça y est nul accordé il a
jamais réussi à passer abdousatarov qui
a battu dinglyen keimer qui va battre
Levon et Magnus qui va perdre contre
Gouch ça ça aurait pu être sympa si la
partie avait un
enjeu c'est dommage qu'elle n'en est
pas Magnus qui choisit qui a choisi la
cadence de leven qui a tout choisi après
dans les parties à enjeu pour être
vraiment sûr d'avoir le maximum de
chance de gagner c'est lui qui a tout
imposé pour que ça lui convienne le plus
possible
ce qui me fume en fait en soi aussi par
qu'en fait la seule raison pour laquelle
on joue pas en 960 en rapide c'est parce
que Carls ne gagne
pas il a jamais gagné un championnat du
monde du coup il a dit la dernière fois
que il fallait que ce soit jouer
en en longue on espère pour lui que
cette fois-ci ça ça suffise pour pour
l'emporter
mais après c'est pas étonnant parce que
comme c'est un jeu plus tactique et
Magnus c'est pas forcément son point le
plus
fort là il va se faire
mater la victoire de
Gash mais donc oui en fait finir en fait
Magnus je pense qu'il gagne pas le
tournoi est déjà un demi sur
de en tout cas ça c'est fini
et keer qui a battu levonevon qui adore
le jeu mais qui se fait qui se fait l
mininer mais peut-être en partie longue
ils seront plus fort après c'est
vraiment difficile de juger des 960 en
partie longue c'est jamais
arrivéingen à
zéing je crois qu'il s'en fich
cyalement bon sur ce les amis on se
retrouve à la pause pour ala contre
contre Magnus à tout de suite les
amis
[Musique]
c'est reparti mesdames et
messieurs est partiz ça bug pour le
moment sur
chesscom allez hop
voilà on a la partie quiose Carl à
firouja on va aller prendre la caméra et
Magnus qui
réfléchit sur cette nouvelle position
magnifique donc je pense qu'il va faire
C4 pour menacer F H7 et petit
rock c'est ce qui paraît logique en fait
mais on va voir parce qu'c le fou en
B1 normalement tu ve jouer C4
attaqueras le pion H7 il va probablement
jouer petit rock pour le défendre al là
évidemment ça bug donc on peut pas
montrer et après
avoir je peux pas montrer parce que ça
bug
ouis je crois que c'est le début de la
partie je mets un petit refresh ouais
c'est non petit rock petit
rock les de joueurs au de premiers
coups
et il joue B4 donc il a vraiment voulu
empêcher
C5 et B4 B6 donc c'est un peu logique he
comme début on va se mettre du côté
d'All res parce qu'en fait on est pour
allier Rea après pas grave hein là comme
je disais ce ces parties-l n'ont pas
d'enjeu c'est vraiment de l'exhibition
pure donc s' a s'il faut battre Magnus
c'est pas forcément maintenant c'était
plutôt avanth là où ça joue un peu pour
quelque chose donc il y a eu C5
ouais ça assez logique hein de toute
façon les deux joueurs avaient envie de
faire C4 C5 donc il a commencé par B4
pour gagner un peu d'espace
là on va vite avoir une position c'est
une position un peu plus normale on va
vite avoir des pièces bien placées des
deux côtés mais ça pourrait un peu se
simplifier quand même je sais pas on va
voir a pas ça veut dire quoi ça compte
pas de points rapide alors le truc c'est
que là les deux premiers jours je je
rappelle c'est le c'est le tournoi de
qualification aujourd'hui et demain sauf
que il y a pas
d'éliminé c'est un concept après hein
c'est la première fois que je vois ce
concept dans ma vie mais euh mais c'est
un
ouais c'est pour le seeding ouais mais
un seeding pour un tournoi qui sera dans
une autre cadence donc il y a pas
vraiment de valeur c'est un peu
particulier donc fait tu peux finir
dernier ou premier ça change rien
c'est quoi l'avantage alors ben je
j'arrive pas à me l'expliquer en fait
j'ai regardz les les LEC sur League of
Legends et sur 10 équipes ils en ont
éliminé deux quand même alors je trouve
ça un peu je trouve ça peu de fait
d'avoir deux éliminations mais c'est
quand même quelque chose là zéro
élimination c'est quand même ça j'avais
jamais vu c'est juste pour le seeding
ouais mais bon un seeding qui prend
25 % du temps du tournoi c'est quand
même un peu
particulier j'avais jamais vu très très
très
honnêtement c'est c'est une nouveauté là
pour moi ça c'est j'avais pourant je
regarde des trucs mais ça j'avais jamais
jamais vraiment
vu bon ça joue symétrique pour le moment
souvent c'est une bonne idée de jouer
symétrique
et ensuite du 960 en longue
ouais
ok va jouer F6 je
pense je pense qu'il va faire F6 mais je
suis pas
sûr
il a aussi cavalier6 il menace le pion
G7 il fait F6 pour le moment cette
partie là est hyper logique tous les
coups sont normaux mais la position est
plus plus normale les tours sont déjà
pas mal placé c'est une bonne position
de départ
ça est-ce qu'il y a un dress code non en
fait les vestes les vestes douteuses je
crois qu'elles ont été données par
l'organisation c'est pour le style en
fait c'est genre en mode c'est hpant que
chacun a sa veste en velours
designé je sais pas enfin j'ai pas
d'avis non plus là j'ai vraiment me
demandez pas les amis ne me demandez pas
en
fait ça put ça me
fracasse
ouais
c'est du côté de chez moi on t'aurait
dit tu te crois au carnaval de
Nice du côté de chez moi on t'aurait dit
ça on aait te demander si si tu te crois
au carnaval de
Nice je t'ai prie pour le clown avat ça
dirait ça chez
moi
non mais ça là au moins on a une vraie
position
quoi en fait j'ai compris l'intérêt du
960 c'est de retomber dans des positions
qui ressemblent aux échecs en fait
tuesèr
tuespères que le jeu t'est pas trop en
pourri quoi mais
ouais je sais pas si je me demande si tu
veux faire passer la dame devant pour
l'activer quand
même je sais pas si ça
peut si tu peux avoir
envie ils ont m écrit une sorte de bio
pour chaque jur c'est c'est une
dinguerie et j'ai toujours du mal à
trouver moi on me l'a envoyé en fait
mais j'ai toujours du mal à trouver le
l'emploi du temps du du tournoi sur le
site c'est ça qui me bute en fait c'est
qu'ils ont pensé à des
détails par contre ce qui est pas mal
c'est que ce plan quand j'ai travaillé à
la télévision en Russie et qu'on devait
faire une émission d'échec on avait
envie de faire un plan comme ça de
mettre une cam par contre le budget il
est pharaonique he pour le tournoi ça
c'est un truc de ouf la prod elle est
vraiment super pour le coup ils ont
vraiment une super prod il y a beaucoup
de caméras des angles de caméras assez
intéressant je pense ils sont à
plusieurs millions de budget sur sur ce
tournoi ils ont vraiment fait des
efforts donc F6 a il joue la symétrie je
me demande si tu peux pas essayer toi de
ouais de jouer du D5 D5 c'est le coup
numéro 2 dame C6 essayer de dribler un
peu les
blancs genre ces plans là ils sont pas
mal après ils sont pas très bien
utilisés mais ils sont pas
mal
pas alors il y avait un bug tout à
l'heure je vais voir si il a été réparé
donc j'avais enlevé parce que ça m'était
la mauvaise position
d'origine et le bug est toujours présent
il a jouer cavalier F7
ok la pauvre depuis en fait tu as la
pauvre depuis la première
rangée je pense qu'il y a une caméra
juste juste au tout début de l'
Chiquet
la partie elle me fracasse quoi
c'est complètement
symétrique
mais la veste d'aliisa en rouge elle me
fascine
ouais vu qu'on voit voyez c'est sur les
Chiquet parce qu'on voit la tour la tour
elle est sur la première rangée donc
c'est ils ont ils ont incrusté des
petites caméra dans dans la
table en vrai c'est stylé quand même
hein
F B7 incoming et je suis pas sûr que tu
as envie de jouer fou B7 moi je jouerai
plutôt pas en fait moi j'erai plutôt
dame C6 depuis tout à l'heureah
d'ailleurs maintenant c'est une
proposition de l'ordi dame C6 je sais
que dans ce jeu faut pas trop bloquer sa
dame
ça réfléchi en tout
cas mais ce sera encore plus intéressant
à partir de dimanche hein quand ce sera
en partie longue il a fait fou B7
j'aurais pas fait fou B7
personnellement
il C son que pour nepoding ouais ouais
non non il y a une il y a un vrai effort
sur la
prod
c'est quoi nouverture bah là il y a plus
de nom en 960 les ouvertures n'ont pas
de nom bah qui en échec
ça a pas de nom en fait
c'est en quoi les noirs sont
mieux bah les noirs sont pas mieux en
fait hein c'est symétrique c'est au
blanc de jouer les blancs sont
sensiblement mieux mais pas
beaucoup
ouais
je pense qu'il va jouer D6 mais c'est un
peu triste peut-être tour C8
alors quand c'est symétrique est-ce que
les blancs peuvent avoir l'avantage
quand car ils ont la main ouais c'est
possibleêre un peu triste d si ça bloque
le fou mais
bon
c'est pas non plus gravissime
hein c'est pas non plus
gravissime
D4 te donne envie al attention un D4 ça
casse ta structure je sais pas si c'est
bon est-ce qu'il y a des positions qui
donnent avantage grand ou blanc
je crois ouais qu'il y en a certaines
qui donnent un vrai avantage
blanc
Magnus qui donne l'impression de
calculer les joueurs sont des Fray il
payent tout de leur poche ce genre de
tour alors non généralement ils sont
même là dans dans ce genre de tour comme
actuellement ils sont même payés pour
jouer au-delà du price pool généralement
ils ont tout fris compris et ils ont
même souvent un
cachet un appirance fille qui leur est
versé al c'est pas tout le temps le cas
c'est pas pour tout le monde mais déjà
ils sont tout défrayé plus il y a de il
y a de la
pierencef
une question commenting c'est pas giga
difficile de commenter 960 que tu peux
pas te raccrocher à les positions que tu
connais tu comprends encore moins bien
les positions que les joue joueur et tu
ne peux pas t'er de l'ordi euh alors le
problème du 960 à commenter c'est
surtout que ça n'intéresse pas les
gens et que ça n'a pas d'enjeu et
d'histoire et que c'est plus difficile à
comprendre bah il y avait quelqu'un qui
en parlait bien dans le chat tout à
l'heure qui était assez
intéressant et qui disait qu'une partie
du plaisir quand tu regardes des parties
d'échec c'est aussi ça ça a des
analogies avec d'autres parties que ça
raconte une histoire qui a un lien entre
l'histoire dans tout ce qui se passe et
cetera avec les parti qu'on joue
nous-même et tout
ça et que là du coup ça disparaît
complètement plus le fait qu'il y a pas
dans jeu plus le fait que les gens
aiment pas le jeu enfin les amateurs en
tout cas il y a quasiment que des points
négatifs ouais
c'est ce que j'avais dit tout à l'heure
euh chesscom ils avaient essayé aussi
avant de faire un peu des événements 960
le club de Saint-Louis aussi avait fait
quelques événements 960 notamment quand
Kasparov avait
rejoué mais dans tous ces cas-là ça a
toujours été des échecs cuisants et et
donc petit à petit ça a disparu
simplement parce que le bah le jeu
n'intéresse pas quoi tu as déjà joué en
960 ouais moi j'ai joué quelques
tournois en 960 au début j'aimais bien
après ça m'a saoulé à vrai
dire
c'est pas un jeu inintéressant mais
bon c'est bien pour les professionnel
quoi en gros mais pas pour les joueurs
amateurs comme moi ni
pour ni pour le
public c'est vraiment un jeu pour pour
les joueurs
professionnels je trouve au moins que là
ça se joue qu' talent et n pas à l'idere
de la prépa ouis mais la prépa ça fait
partie du jeu en fait hein enfin que
vous le vouliez ou non en fait les
livres et la théorie aux échecs c'est
inhérent au
jeu même si moi je suis le premier à pas
aimer la théorie mais gen les premiers
livres de théorie pourrait même remonter
avant Rui Lopez mais Rui Lopez il a déjà
théorisé plein de choses dans l'espagnol
dans la berlinoise pour le coup et c'est
des livres qui ont été écrit il y a déjà
600 ans il se trouve que ça fait partie
du
jeu
ça a toujours existé ça existera
toujours après le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que les préparations vont trop
loin donc la seule manière de les
limiter c'est de faire la chose la plus
logique au monde c'est de raccourcir les
cadences les joueurs vont tellement loin
dans les parties grâce à leur
préparation que c'est normal qu'ils
aient moins de temps pour les pour
pouvoir les mettre en place c'est juste
l'évolution logique
mais
c'est c'est c'est une telle évidence en
fait et encore quand rapide maintenant
aussi he il y a beaucoup de prépas mais
ça limite quand
même ça limite son importance en tout
cas
mais je pense pas que l'avenir des
échecs ce soit les cadence longue en 960
après je me trompe peut-être et les gens
vont peut-être adorer et se dire ah ben
tiens on adore les parties en 960 qui
durent 5h et demi hein
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas cette impression
en tout cas la Magnus il commence
peut-être avoir un petit quelque chose
mais ouais non je sais
pas l'impression que juste qu'on a du
mal à placer ce cavalier
ici on se prend vite du
F4 x 4 ouais les blancs sont un tout
petit peu en avance position est pas
évidente x 5 c'est bien joué je
crois mais en quoi l'accélération de la
cadence limite l'importance la prépare
on pourrait penser en qu' rapide c'est
mieux préparer ah ben en fait pour deux
raisons première raison déjà en rapide
c'est plus difficile de se rappeler de
sa prépa c'est vraiment plus difficile
de reconstruire sa prépa donc tu peux te
baser dessus mais tu peux plus
facilement euh
te planter entre
guillemets parce que tu as moins de
temps pour reconstruire le fichier dans
ta tête et la deuxième raison c'est que
le di diapason des choses que tu peux
jouer en rapide est un peu plus
important parce que tu peux te permettre
de jouer un truc un poil
douteux si ça pose un souci pratique un
peu plus compliqué à l'adversaire donc
ça élargit non seulement ça ça rend plus
difficile
la la régurgitation de ta préparation
mais en plus ça élargit le diapason des
possibilités de l'adversaire en quelque
sorte donc pour ces deux raisons en fait
ça fait que la prépa est un peu moins
importante en rapide même si si tu
passes une belle prépa tu vas quand même
faire mal et l'autre raison aussi c'est
que tu peux jouer plus de parties au
lieu de jouer une partie en 6h tu peux
théoriquement jouer quatre donc sur un
match en quatre partie même si tu
arrives à placer une prépa une fois sur
les quatre qui fait vraiment mal bah
l'adversaire s'il est plus fort que toi
il a quand même trois parti pour pour
faire
l'écart
et après une fois que tu as un avantage
les positions sont plus difficiles à
transformer parce que tu as un peu moins
de temps enin plus difficile quand tu
joues contre plus fort que toi en tout
cas et donc même un joueur plus fort qui
se serait pris qui serait un peu moins
bien à la sortie de l'ouverture il
faudrait encore réussir à le battre ce
qui sera aussi plus
dur
aujourd'hui on en a 4 et demain 3
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on en ait 7 7 et 7
mais c'est pas le pas le cas qu'
Pat donc pour un pour un tas de
raisons pour un tas de raisons
multiples les prépas sont aujourd'hui en
tout cas pour le moment plus plus
efficace en en longue après peut-être
que tu reviens dans 10 ans et même en 15
+ 3 les prépas font mal
hein d'illeurs comme je le disais
avanthier la plus belle partie qu'on a
vu de la du dernier champion ch tour
c'est celle où Magnus et alirea ont joué
une longue prépa de 20 ou 25 coups mais
au final ça a donné une super partie
parce que même si la position était
égale ben comme les deux joueurs ont pas
trop de temps avec la position
intéressante ça donne un vrai combat et
Magnus commence à faire mal ouais ses
pièces sont mieux placées à lirea on l'a
vu hein il a le D6 c'était pas
terrible mais bon c'est pas fait encore
ça reste
solide c'est ai parce qu'il lâche pas
leur grosse pré pour les rapides mais
les garanties mais g pour les longues
c'est beaucoup moins le cas aujourd'hui
que qu'avantv il sortent de plus en plus
de grosses prép rapid mais c'est juste
qu'elles sont plus difficiles à sortir
c'est juste plus difficile en fait tu as
moins de temps
donc et le diapason adverse est large
quoi et puis tu joues plusieurs parties
dans la même journée enfin il y a tout
un tas de choses qui font que c'est plus
difficile il y a une multitude de
facteurs différents on a bien vu ikarou
qui joue 4 5 cavalier F3 cavalier F6
cavalier prend5 cavalier prend4 là je
peux pas montrer le le truc mais qui a
joué ça même en en rapide en fait tu
peux te retrouver à jouer des trucs qui
sont censé être un peu douteux mais on
avait vu ala faire une bonne partie dans
une scandinave contre Magnus en fait tu
peux jouer tellement plus de choses
aussi en rapide que l'adversaire a plus
de mal à enfin pas plus de mal à ciblé
mais tu peux tu peux surprendre de
beaucoup plus de manières
différentes quand tu par rapide c'est
quelle cadence je pense la cadence reine
du rapide c'est 15 +
la je chense qu' va jouer tour C8 mais
le cavalier va devoir aller en H8 ça va
être terrible allierisin un peu le D6
c'était vraiment la faute de cette
partie il va la perdre celle
lira je
pense mais t C8 est-ce que s'il a pas le
temps de faire F5 on a peut-être F prend
C4 quand
même puis on prend F6 prend F1 puis on
prend F7 on reprend il do peut-être
tenter ça et tour C8 du coup sil
renforce par fou B3 peut-être tour D8 et
sur F5 cavalier F8 ouais mais la
position elle est dur
hein je pense que la position d'alirea
est dure hein
mais oui son D6 là il était vraiment
ouais je pense c'était ça l'erreur on a
senti que le coup les autres coups ça
allit comme ça on a senti que tour C8
c'était plus plus efficace quoi ça va à
rien de fermer ce fou là qui qui qui
veillait bien
qui Magnus a fait la même chose mais pas
tout à fait en plus finalement à 5 ça a
ramené la dame en
jeu finalement nous on a toujours Notre
Dame cachée ouais il Magnus il a réussi
à gagner des temps quoi à un moment
donné celui qui gagne le tour est
considéré comme le champion du monde de
la catégorie ça se joue autre part alors
il y a je crois que le championnat du
monde de 960 a été annulé donc non il
sera pas considéré comme champion du
monde il sera considéré comme rien en
fait toute façon tu peux pas faire un
championnat du monde sur un invit
national avec personnes qui sont trié
sur le volet par Magnus c'est c'est
carrément Magnus qui a invité les qui
qui qui a fait la liste des gens invité
quoi c'est pas il y a rien qui va donc
non il sera pas champion du monde le
champion du monde restera
malheureusement Magnus Magnus Carlsen Mo
ikarou Nakamura à notre grand regret
évidemment
mais ça restera Nakamura à point
barre
mais non là ça peut pas décerner un
titre de champion du monde c'est
impossible
F F des5 ça va faire très très mal
ouais
une camura d'après ce que j'ai compris
il est pas invité il était invité pardon
mais il a il est pas venu parce qu'il va
jouer les candidats et que et qu'il
préfère se préparer je pense qu'il a
bien
raison s'il a prévu sa
période d'entraînement de pas venir
perdre son temps sur ce tournoi en fait
F F tu as pas t prend des7
d'ailleursend F7 aussi peut-être jouable
prend des
6 il y a peut-être un truc avec puion
prend des4 après is la il se fait
exploser
là
D5 ça fait tellement
mal
cavalier F5 a l'air fort
aussi ah ouais la position est tellement
dur pour les
noirs
je crois que ça marche pas tout de suite
non il y a à mon avis il y a un problème
de pion prend des4 intermédiaire quelque
part en fait je crois que si tu
prends prends prends il puis prend là et
si tu prends du coup il touche ta tour
et si tu prends prends prends il a dame
1 je crois que c'est ça le
problème alors cavalier F5 c'est hyper
logique ça l'air hyper fort mais se
trouve que c'est pas pas bon à cause de
D5
ouais très dur à
trouver
du coup il a pas
trouvé mais c'était vraiment dur et dam
c'est si c'est logique en
plus
Magnus qui
réfléchit
en tout cas très beau tournoi très bien
réalisé il y a rien à
dire
est-ce qu'il a un campleinorité de la
part d'alii face à Magnus pas du
tout
non la retransmission est vraiment
excellente est-ce que je vais stream sur
ma chaîne ce soir non là pendant tout ce
tournoi là pendant les 8 jours je
streamerai peut-être avant quelquefois
mais pas après ça dure trop
longtemps sauf mardi peut-être pour Mazo
si joue le title du soir
mais sinon on va pouvoir se délecter là
pendant 8 jours devant devant ce tournoi
ça va vraiment être extraordinaire là là
c'est
vraiment le SOMUM
de du divertissement
là ça va être le
SOMUM hâte de voir les parties longues
oh que oui
parti long qui vont être
exceptionnel ça joue que la semaine ou
aussi le weekend ah non ça joue 8 jours
d'affilé là ça va être tous les jours
tous les jours à partir de 13h là à
fond
tu vas pas le rater Ruby quand même ah
ben non ça va pas rater hein je vais
quand même mettre le téléphone demain
pour regarder en même temps j'espère que
vous ferez tous pareil on va quand même
pas rater France
Écosse ni Angleterre pays de Gal
attention quand même
hein
non mais là le truc qui est difficile en
plus dans C dans dans cette phase de
Calif c'est que ça joue vraiment pour
rien c'est
dur toute façon il y a il y a un signe
si vous voyez Corneto pas regarder un
tournoi c'est qu'il y a un
problème il réserve va s'en sortir de ce
truc là il va prendre D4 je pense d
prendre des4 C4
ah ça a l'air d'être tendu de chez tendu
parce qu'il y a un ma en G7 en fait si
tu prends D4 prends D4 prends C4 il y a
dame G7
math qu'est-ce que ça va donner ce trucl
à la
fin
il dit dans le chat j'habite en Écosse
et j'ai presque envie qu'il gagne car la
France c'est la kata
[Rires]
euh alors j'espère que le presque est
réel
hein euh j'espère que le presque réel
ici côté Michael the
mode 18 ans en Écosse ça pèse qu'est-ce
que tu allais faire en Écosse pourquoi
tu es en Écosse
toi B le seul coup c'est cavalier F4
apparemment mais ça sent que la position
elle est quasiment foutue mais c'est
incroyable que cavalier F4
tienne
anal qui pour une boîte live science à
côté de Glasgow
original la fait ro
H8 s'enlève du
clouage
on a quelqu'un qui est pas convaincu par
Maxime
Lucu dans le chat moi j'aime bien Maxime
Luc il est pas mauvais hein toute façon
si tu as pas Antoine Dupont tu mets qui
à la place tu mets Baptiste
serin
astoy je sais pas qu' veut
mettre
tu mets le garec à la place de
Lucu non mais jeis pas qui tu veux
mettre à la
place ça le
problème
vous voulez mettre Ramos en
UF autant tu mets Camille Lopez
hein autant tu mets Camille Lopez
frère pourquoi
s'embêter avec T j en Ramos mais oui
mais du coup tu mets qui en
15 Ramos il est trop fort en 15 pourquoi
tu veux l'enlever de du
ala ça a pas l'air de bien se passer
c'est visuelle he la position
là le garec jauno non mais bon Lucu il
est nettement plus fort que le gare est
jauno arrêtez
cavalier D6 vous voulez faire
mais le pion il va fil à adame he
frérot Vakatawa il devient quoi on sait
pas
d B7 ça tient
pas7 qui prend B7 je crois mais dam
B6 les AM je le fais pas à cause de
tourb1 je
pense
je trouve notre équipe elle a un tout
petit peu régressé là quand même Gabin
villire on a quelques joueurs clés là
qui qui sont
plus il était vraiment fort là je sais
pas s'il est blessé ou pas en tout cas
il avait
régressé du P on l'a pas on a toujours
pas comment il s'appelle déjà mais à fou
en deè Lig ça va nous faire du bien
quand
même will MC il est un peu moyen en ce
moment Kamali il a
il a régressé aussi dentil je crois
qu'il a juste trop
joué fikou enfin en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'on a plein de joueurs on
a on a en tête leur niveau de 2022 et
pas de 2023
2024 on a pas tamac aussi qui est hyper
fort
wi
énormissime ouais la saison dernière
avec le Racing wi il était
moyen rugby les S sont beaucoup plus
courts qu'au foot ouais au rugby les si
sont très courts tu peux même avoir un
mec qui est fort pendant un ou 2 ans et
qui après devient
claqué après il est très très bon il
reste souvent bon à long terme mais tu
as des joueurs ils peuvent être en
pleine Bour pendant deux saisons non et
après ils sont ils sont
clacos mais pour moi ouais quand il va y
avoir mais à fou déjà ça va changer pas
mal de choses ça va tellement faire du
bien tu lag bonne nouvelle ouais il va
être bon il va être très très bon il est
un peu jeune encore mais il va être très
très bon quand tu vas avoir tilagi
et
et et mets à fou en deuxième ligne tu
vas faire
malin tu vas faire très mal em
mêlé tu vas faire tellement
mal d'ailleurs tu peux même pas passer
un flamant ou quoi il va jouer dame B6
il a trouvé le seul coup il va décaler
la tour en B1 et cavalier D6 maintenant
comme ça quand il prend B6 la tour est
en prise c'est très très bien
joué je sais pas si tu peux avoir tu la
game mais à fou ensemble tu as plus de
sauteur bah tu t'en fiches typothèque la
touche et tu défonces tout
quoi
qui prend C4 au moins la tour restera en
prise réuss à la tenir c'est un
exploitpothèque la tou c'est nouvelle
stratégie ouais tuas plus rien à faire
quoiypothèque la touche tu es là pour
les
défoncer mais ouais faudrait changer de
centre à il faut repasser comment il
s'appelle là le Bordelet Biar là je
rappelle jamais son nom enlever mes Mo
fana peut-être Mo fana le passer au
centre mais bon Mo fana moi il me
convent jamais enfin je sais pas ce
qu'on doit
faire Mo fana on peut le mettre au
centre mais Mo fana ouais non mais il
est fort mais
bon tu mets la place de dentil du coup
mais bon tu gardes ficou ouais je sais
pas
c'est on était tellement fort il y a 2
ans on reste hyper fort hein mais euh
mais on est enfin pour moi le
déplacement d'Écosse là c'est 5050
hein
c'est bizarre parce que c'est les mêmes
joueurs quasiment ça a tellement envie
de tourner bon après c'est sûr qu'il
nous manque B il te manque quand même du
pon il manque quand même tamac il te
manque Mfou qui va arriver il te manque
il te manque flamand il te manque du
monde en
vrai mais après je pense cette année
notre objectif rugby c'est de gagner les
les JO je pense c'est le seul sport que
je vais vraiment regarder
assisument il prend
prend ça reprendre de la tour d' prend
D6 qui dit les termes je vais
regarder
il dit les termes
ouais
ah le pingpong aussi avec les frères
lebrin ouais je suis
d'accord
prenons pour du main victoire de
l'Écosse
le toujours sympa ouais non il y a
quelques sport sympa c'est
vrai mais bon pour moi rudby 7 c'est le
main event on a déjà perdu la Coupe du
monde après je sais pas si on est favori
ou
pas l'équipe sera tellement différente
de celle qui joue sur le circuit
international
les équipes seront d'ailleurs
relativement
différentes je pense qu'un Antoine
Dupont à 7 il fait très
mal cavalier cavalier F4 je
pense sont fort à 7 ils sont champion
olympique ouais les Argentins aussi mais
équipe seront seront différentes on va
voir on a qui qui vient du 15 on a d
pont
ah Dupon il va Dupon c'est le meilleur
joueur du monde à 7 c'est sûr il est
tellement
fort cavalier 6 c'est quand même logique
hein il vient vient se
placer cavalier 4 c'était logique
aussi je pense pas c'est bien différent
le rugby a
7 bah c'est différent mais le truc c'est
que d pont en fait il est tellement
complet comme joueur il court vite il
plaque bien il a une il est bon enfin il
a tout en fait du pont genre jaliberère
je serais moins sûr
déjà ah mais si on a que du pont c'est
pas bon on n pas genre Olivon je pense
qu'il serait bon à 7
c'est ce que j'ber j'ber à 7 il serait
nul il pourrait ce serait
catastrophique c'est plutôt les capacité
physique à 7 alors que à 15 du point
FAAD par sa vision de jeer sa vista non
mais 7 tu as aussi la vision de je la
vista Makalou ouais malalou aussi hyper
fort à 7 Makalou
monstrueux V 7 ce serait très fort ouais
je crois aussi ouais je crois que
Vakatawa et tedburawa c'est pas mal si
on les mettait à
7 flamand il doit être monstrueux à
vient du mais on sait que vakata vient
du 7 frère pour ça que j'ai vakata éta
dit bwa qui étai les deux les deux
grandes stars de ctist
français Flaman trop lourd pas sûr il y
a des secondes lignes qui sont bons à à
7 il faut tout pour faire du 7 mais tu
regardes du 7 ou pas
Damien P à 7 ça doit être bien aussi
ouais movaka 7 ça peut être pas mal
aussi ouais mais normalement c'est plus
des
h sait pas défendre il sait défendre
hein quand même
mais normalement les ailiers je pense
c'est plutôt d pont qui aurait ce rôle
là cavalier 7 dame G4 dame G4 ça a l'air
de faire
mal aldrit je sais pas ce que ça
donnerait il y a pas un tour F7 dam H4
là doit pas y avoir ça se défend
comment tour F7 qui prend D5 dame H4
dame B6 roi H1 il y a dame B1 et ro F1
il y a dame B1
aussi donc il est parti en
A4 serait trop lourd
ou
et celui était bon c'était comment il
s'appelait le troisème ligne qui a joué
à
Toulon qui était bon pour le coup à
7 à tour à 8 seul coup dur mais après ça
défend la tour et le pion mais bon dur
quand même
8 wi à 7 ça le fait ouais wi ça doit le
faire à 7 aussi je suis
d'accord mais bon si vous prenez burawa
il était il faisait 1,70 hein il était
petit il était pas costaud et c'était un
des plus forts joueurs à 7 du
monde il y a pas il y a aussi la
vivacité hein faut pas forcer forcment
être que physique hein un joueur
rapide qui est pas trop dégueu sur les
plaages il peut faire très très mal he
même en étant petit parce qu'il peut
vraiment faire la
DIF biaré ça peut faire mal mais bon
faut pas avoir que des enin faut avoir
des profils différents
pour récupérer les ballons genre au
centre à movaka ça peut enfin movaka en
grande forme ça peut faire mal peut
récupérer beaucoup de ballons
va peut-être la tenir je sais pas la
position elle paraît tellement du pour
alirea j'aimerais bien qu'il la tienne
mais après c'est pas éliminatoire donc
c'est un peu dommage là il va faire dame
prendre5 et bah il est obligé de toute
façon d prend des 5 seul coup parce que
sinon il y a cavalier ici et sur damage
4 dame D4
échece le plus rapide du monde la [__]
là
euh c'était comment il s'appelle Perry
comment il s'appelait déjà les lier l'
américain là qui était si fort ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas j'ai pas pu voir
de
match il doit plus jouer Perry Baker
non tu tellement fort
lui non non mais c'est c'est c'est c'est
actuel mais le joueur mythique c'était
Baker
le joueur mythique c'était bcker qui qui
sur son elle faisait mal un qui aurait
été très fort à 7 si vous vous rappelez
c'était le
Biaro lui il aurait été monstrueux à 7
bah comme
abana des ailiers comme ça c'est ça cl
ouais Magnus il va pas la gagner celle
ça bien été tenue par
alirea et dam 4 dame
D4 bah là c'est Dame D4 échec et ça va
Dr je crois qu'il est vraiment obligé de
dame D4 ouais c'est
joué force leschang des
dames
énorme défense he ouais ouais non il a
hyper bien défendu là mais est-ce qu'il
peut même tenter de jouer pour le gain
avec un tour 8 pas piquer des anenton
pour essayer de couper le roi après
paraît dangereux quand
même Ding va être à 0 sur 3 après c'est
tellement difficile a jouer les tournois
sans
enjeu et d'ailleurs c'est pas mal qu'on
ait parlé du 7 parce que ça fait une
super transition avec le
960 parce que le 7 c'est pas entre
guillemets du du 13 ou du 15 mais c'est
quand même très sypa à regarder parce
que ça apporte quelque chose de
différent et de
divertissant alors que le 960 ça marche
pas
vraiment mais parce que c'est un peu de
l'exhibition le le rugby enfin je sais
pas c'est rapide c'est sympain moi
j'aime j'aime beaucoup regarder du 7 ça
peut même arriver que je préfère
regarder du 7 que du 15 suivant les
matchs alors que je vais jamais préférer
du 960 sur du
classique mais c'est parce que ça ouais
mais je comprends pourquoi en fait mais
j'ai du mal à
l'exprimer le 7 c'est un jeu sympa c'est
rapide et puis tu retrouves quand même
des belles actions de de 15 mais en mais
en mais en plus
rapide moi je jouer cavalier C6 mais
l'ordi valide
pas
il va jouer tour D8 je
pense ah il peut aussi faire tour B8 et
tour B2 peut-être tour B8 à vrai dire le
7 c'est du ouais c'est ça le 7 c'est du
Blitz ouais c'est que du changement de
cadence c'est pas ça change pas le jeu
ouais leur dit donne tout pour faire nul
moi j'aurais fait tour B8 je
pense
c'est parce que c'est pas trop une 960
classique en fait ils ont fait une 960
en rapide ça toujours flopppe et donc là
ils essayent le 960 en
classique mais je vois pas pourquoi ça
floppperait pas en
fait on verra il fait tour
F8 il va la tenir
ala
eux ils pensent pas ils pensent au
contraire que ça va être hyper
hpant va faire tour B8
maintenant
et c'est bizarre d'avoir fait tour
F8 ah le 13 moi j'ai jamais accroché
nicolot bizarrement parce que c'est beau
sport mais je sais pas jamais
accroché
ouais t pour5 c'est plus logique c'est
plus il y a plus de lion iless d'aller
gagner a
et ronne avantage blanc à cause de
cavalier
E4 bizarre ce qu'il a fait quand même
ala
là le foot australien j'ai déjà vu le
foot australien c'est beau sport aussi
le foot
australien
je crois qu'il va finir par perdre ala
en en ayant fait nimp il y a pas les
temps avec des opening prédéfinis
euh il va y avoir un truc je crois en
mai qui pour le coup a l'air plutôt
intéressant
ou il vont prendre des positions qui
sont égales tiré de parties très connu
et les joueurs devront les
jouer c'est un truc un peu bizarre c'est
que il y a des joueurs qui peuvent les
avoir
étudié retour du gamb ouais bah ça va
être un peu dans optique là sauf que ça
ê des positions entre guillemets
égales mais gambirice en vrai je trouve
c'est plus intéressant que
960 la vidéo est très bien d'ailleurs je
vous la
recommande dans l'esprit après le
gambirille c'est trop
pourri non c'est roi des4 qui prend à4
qui
C3 ça m'a l'air dangereux ro
D4 a C C3 il va jouer cavalier
B2 pas si simple peut-être de faire nul
k B2
D2 les blancs vont être mieux Baha ouais
il a pas très bien géré ça finale
ah du coup il fait cavalier E4 mais
attention peut-être bien joué
ça
Magnus qui suit en tout
cas je pense qu'il va jouer D2
là ro
C3
ouais j'ai l'impression qu'il va la
perdre parce que là A4 ça me paraît
chiant parce qu'en fait si tu fais
cavalier C3 cavalier prend C3 ro prend
C3 et ro
D1 tu vas devoir faire ro C1 mais il va
commencer à te faire H4 de l'autre côté
ah il est à de doigt de la perdre en
fait il a vraiment pas bien joué àirea
il est pas rentré dans la bonne
finale
jouer
cavalier3ord nul après cavalier B3 A6
cavalier D4 roi bouge et cavalier F5
c'est la seule
chance il faut trouver cavalier B3 je
pense ou cavalier 6 cavalier ça doit
perdre je pense
ah peut-être pas parce qu'il veut H4
cavalier
B4 ah mais il a vraiment mal joué là
encore je pense qu'il doit faire
cavalier C6 à6 cavalier D4 roi F2 roi
prend D1 A7 roi bouge et ça va faire
dame dame non ça va il a pas mal joué
j'ai rien
dit ça va
tenir ça va tenir bah toute façon on le
voit à la jauge hein
Maxime tout estydro mais attention
Maxime
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il s'est mis en
danger tout seul quand même mais
maintenant oui ça va il peut même faire
cavalier B3 là H5 et revenir avec le
cheval s'il touche la case F5 après
c'est nul tout de suite siement H6 c'est
nul tout de suite il le fait comme ça
c'est pareil
k D4 k
F5 mais moi je dis a quand même eu
chaud moi je dis là quand même eu
chaud F4 cavalier h c'est ça
après
c'est nul tout
seul et voilà le travail donc nul Magnus
qui a réussi pas à passer CER qui a
battu dingly r Ding qui se fait exploser
0 sur 3
gouche domarajou et oui qui bat le fan
de 960 Levon mais bon comme je le disais
c'est pas là que ça va jouer
et et match nul entre abdousorov et
etbec au classement ça c'est là que le
le glas va va blesser pour pour Magnus
puisqu'il est à un point sur
3 alors que Vincent keer est déjà à 2 et
demi Magnus qui va pas remporter ce ce
tournoi probablement heureusement que il
a milité pour pour les cadences longues
pour le
960 parce que sinon c'est pas le plus
fort en espérant
que
son pressing politique
suffise à le faire gagner donc on va se
faire une petite pause et on revient un
petit peu plus tard pour l'ultime partie
de la journée à bientôt les amis à tout
de
[Musique]
suite
les amis ça va reprendre vous avez pu
voir les joueurs un petit peu analyser
entre eux les parties on va aller
chercher la la partie d'Ali
Reza voilà c'est la caméra d'aliire
Reza il va jouer contre Nobe on va voir
comment il débute la partie hein j'ai
l'impression qu'il a eu beaucoup de 3 C4
c'était les coups que j'avais moi
aussi de CER et et Carlsen en tout cas
ça a beaucoup pensé à à faire
ça aller chercher l'activité euh de la
dame et du fou
mais on va voir comment il réussissent à
à à mettre en place leur
développement donc j'ai trois premiers
coups c'est logique
on développe le fionqueto
quoi et surtout on laisse pas le fou
venir en fianqueto en
face donc il joue C6 je je m'étais
questionné sur ce
coup mais attention un côté noir de pas
se prendre un cavalier F 3 et D4 là ça
pourrait aller vite pour alerza
après je sais pas trop comment il
compte continuer sur cavalier F3
D4 en FR ça çaoc est possible en fait tu
ça ça va va créer une possibilité une
situation de rock normal enfin tu vas
voir quand ça va se passer c'est pas
très intuitif mais une fois qu'on sait
comment ça marche c'est
facile en gros tu vas te retrouver avec
le roi en G1 ou le roi en C1 et la tour
en D1 mais il faut vider les pièces qui
gênent au milieu
quoiordi donne bien cavalier GF3
cavalier gf6 et D4 comme ligne
principale ça tombe bien c'est les coups
les plus
logique est-ce queajimer je pense pas
parce que je crois pas que les joueurs
qui analysent entre eux soi ceux qui qui
jouent
entre c'est tellement logique de vouloir
faire D4 en fait k F3 c'est tellement
logique comme coup c'est fou comme ça
après tu fais DK tu peux mettre
peut-être l'autre cavalier en D3 en
C2 la caméra est juste derrière le roi
on la voit
là il joue F4 ah il veut jouer F4 avant
cavalier F3 ambitieux ça bloque un peu
le
fou
ça se pas bien ce év dél robinide ouais
c'est un événement assez extraordinaire
c'est peutêtre bien jouer F4 en fait
c'est peut-être meilleur
encore c'est un événement vraiment
exceptionnel
robinide surtout cette cette phase de
qualification qui n'élimine personne
assez exceptionnel bon l'ordi déteste
finalement après une plus grande
profondeur mais bon c'est pas si
clair
une phase de
qualification c'est un des rares tournoi
de l'année que je suisù je me dis tiens
je vais pas faire de vidéos de recap
c'est parti c'est rarissime
mais c'est le
cas c'est
vrai dans son élément dans ce format bah
il est pas leader du tournoi non plus
puis il y a pas mal de réussite dans C
dans ce jeu
aussi je sais pas les il joue bien la
dernièrement
globalement c'est qualification de la
LEC avec seulement deux non qualifiés
non là il y a zéro non qualifiés
redstone c'estàd qu'ils ont vu là ce
qu'avait fait la LEC et ils ont poussé
le concept plus loin mais oui je suis
d'accord avec toi que déjà la LEC avoir
que que H enfin avoir 8 qualifiés sur 10
ça me paraît déjà assez
spécial c'est pas trop mon kiff mais là
ils ont ils ont poussé le
délire ils ont poussé le délire LEC
jusqu'au
bout
pour être sûr de vexer personne
ouais c'est
ça on le F4 après est logique hein
franchement faute d'après l'ordi mais
hyper
logique
Ding à l'air à la rue ouais mais Ding le
pauvre dans cette partie est-ce que il
se fait défoncer
encore le pauvre Ding
robinide je sais même pas pourquoi il
est
venu sûrement pour l'Argentin c'est je
pense que tout le monde est très très
bien payé mais
ouais
ouais ouais je pense je pense que les
joueurs ont un énorme des énormes
starting fe robinside je pense pour
certains de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros vu la communication sur
les réseaux sociaux et tout ce qu'on
voit vu le mal qui se donne pour dire
que l'événement est absolument
extraordinaire sur les réseaux sociaux
et tu as l'impression que tout est une
nouvelle invention géniale c'est qu'ils
ont dû il doit mettre beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
parce qu'ils le font jamais même pour
des trucs où il y a déjà beaucoup de
tunes jamais à ce point-là en tout cas
donc je pense qu'ils ont dû aligner des
sommes
astronomiques
ni F D3 bon la turbine comprend rien je
sais pas ce qu'elle fait elle est
complètement
buggée après pour le coup robinide ses
an de caméra là dans l'échiquier c'est
unin moi quand j'ai travaillé à la télé
en Russie on avait eu le projet de faire
ça mais on voulait faire des échiquiers
en
vert
pour pouvoir mettre la caméra sous une
case on a la vraie évaluation de l'ordi
je sais pas comment c'est moins 40 ce
truc là honnêtement je pense que l'ordi
est buggé
là là je crois qu'elle est vraiment à la
rue parce que ça peut pas être trop bien
pour les Noirs non plus ce truc là
peut-être qu' c'est pas qu'on peut Roer
ou j'en sais rien
moi est-ce que l' verion est moins
fiable car l'ordi aurit moins appris
alors l'ordi il apprend pas en
fait enin sauf avec les nouvelles techno
mais grosso modo c'est plus du
calcul mais je peux pas croire que les
vales de ce truc là soit moin 30
veut juste jouer 3 et grand rock hein
ais bon c'est nimpe les vales que je
peux vous dire que son premier coup là
c'est fouprend des qu donc oui ça a
complètement
buggé par contre là son premier coup
c'est petit
rock donc il a vraiment l'air de penser
que les noirs sont nettement
mieux
ce qui m'étonne
mais en fait il veut jouer avec B5 est
complètement tapé mais c'est vrai que
f44 sur F4 j'ai pas trop aimé je pensais
qu'il allait vraiment mettre les pions
D4 et C4 comme
un comme une ouverture normale en
fait
après est-ce que les 960 ça accentuit
pas le gouff qu'on a avec les ordis oui
oui bien sûr il y a plus de différence
entre les ordis et nous en 960 qu'aux
échecs normaux parce que nous sommes des
êtres bêtes par rapport aux ordinateurs
pour les échecs en tout cas et donc on
le fait qu'on puisse se raccrocher à des
schémas qu'on apprend ça nous permet de
mieux
jouer mais donc la règle du rock ou vous
voyez il est allé vers sa tour il fait
le petit rock là si le cavalier G1
disparaî on pourra faire petit rock si
le fou c'est un disparais on pourra
faire grand
rock faut dégager le chemin
quoi faut dégager tout ce qu'il y a
entre D1 et G1 Gross
o et tu auras le droit de
roquer en gros c'est
ça
for échec je demandé de cuisiner un
gâteau au chocolat il va moins faire le
malin alors pour le coup je crois que la
plupart des des biscuits que tu achètes
en supermarché sont faits par par des
machines je crois que les machines nous
supplantent plus ou moins dans tout sauf
dans la création de machine
ça marche si au début les deux tours
sont du même côté alors ça peut pas
arriver ah les Robots de cuisine sont
très puissants hein pour faire la
cuisine
les frèes créant des existe déjà je sais
je sais c'est pour ça que je disais ça
parce que ça va arriver et on va devenir
complètement inutile mais on pourra
toujours jouer au 960 beau
jeu
donc il a joué B5
ok B l'ORD est complètement désespéré CB
il joue C5 là puis dame prend B5
en fait il dit que les Blancs ont un
énorme problème de développement de
coordination même k prend B5 k D4 mais
oui après c'est un peu honnêtement c'est
un peu bizarre ce qu'a fait ala quoi
qu'il en
soit a vraiment bien
joué en fait il s'est bloqué les fous
quoi c'est bloqué les ses propres
pièces
il a pas forcément respecté les
principes
ouais
[Musique]
bon on va voir s'il s'en
sort
ça
réfléchit
complexe complexe complexe pour
alira complexe
complexe
la dame va le cavalier va arriver en B5
et D4
ou la dame va prendre et le pion D3 va
être sensible avec FO 6 qui
arrive il se refait
exploser
ouais je crois qu'il est vraiment pas
dedans hein je crois que Ding il est
vraiment pas
dedans
donc dame prend B5
jouer et cavalier H3 bon il est moins
bien
mais honnêtement l'ordi il abuse un peu
humainement on voit pas ça comme
ça
il a joué cavalier
H3 maisessage avec les échecs frère
terrible c'est
terrible qui va voloir jouer petit rock
et tour d pour voir que les pièces
noires vont être mieux
placé mais il va mettre le cavali en F2
il va essayer de tout
défendre l'évaluation est
sévère l'évaluation de l'ordinateur est
vraiment
sévère mais après on voit que le fou le
fou H8 est quand même hyper fort on voit
que le fou G2 est un peu
naze on voit que la colonne B est
intéressante en fait on voit que les
Noirs ils ont les priorité sur toutes
les colonnes et les diagonales
intéressantes cependant l'évaluation
reste cher là il va faire petit
rock là il va jouer petit rock c'est sûr
ouais c'est fait donc vous voyez hein
c'est la règle spéciale x 6 là il va
mettre la tour en
D1 Aronian se fait défoncer par
Magnus après Aronian ça fait un moment
qu'il est pas ouf ouf en échec normaux
non plus
hein c'est en soit pas super
étonnant après c'est dommage
pour pour Levon qui est un grand avocat
du jeu depuis
depuis depuis des années mais après il a
dit plusieurs fois Rian qu'il adorait ce
jeu mais que ça marcherait jamais parce
que c'était trop dur pour les
amateurs pr on verra comme je disais en
partie longue hein personne n'a jamais
joué à ce jeu en partie
longue j'ai jamais vu une compétition en
partie longue je pense que juste
personne n'a jamais joué au jeu en
fait
t B8 re la tour en B1 je
suppose et gche ouais bon ding ding il
se fait exploser à toutes les
games ça juste le saouler d'être là en
fait
non mais ça peut marcher s'il y a une
nouvelle métarent par exemple comme tu
suggérais tout à l'heure pas changer la
position à chaque fois ah peut-être s'il
y a une Mét parent ça peut fonctionner
mais si tu changes à chaque partie je
vois pas dans quel monde les gens vont
s'y intéresser en fait c'est genre un
TFT où tu changerais euh où tu aurais
des patchs à chaque partie en fait je
vois pas comment ça peut
fonctionner mais après euh peut-être que
je me trompe
hein a 4 très jouable quoi c'est encore
encore un 1è affaiblissement je pense
Pasin ça celui qui a la meilleure
turbine la Meille mais arrêtez de dire
que c'est celui qui a la meilleure
turbine la Meille mémoire Pando je
comprends pas pourquoi vous dites
ça tu as bien vu que moi rien qu'en
Blitz en jouant nashdorf et machin là
comment s'appelait l'autre Nimzo où je
connais pas un seul coup de théorie je
suis monté à 28 40 sur chesscom Ikaru en
jouant le B cl il monte à
3100 c'est c'est les échecs c'est pas
enfin arrêtez de penser ça en
fait faut arrêter de penser
ça c'est ce qui est
important ça fait la différence après à
la marge pour le top top niveau mais
c'est
tout
après les changements de position chaque
partie pe correspondre à l'aléatoire de
TF non mais bon les gars c'est juste
trop compliqué comme
jeu avec la mme position de départ
pendant an ça être un concours de
mémoire mais non mais imaginez qu'aux
échecs en fait il y a des nouvelles
idées qui arrivent tout le
temps c'est juste qu'il doit pas y avoir
beaucoup de positions 960 qui sont
intéressantes je pense peut-être 20 ou
30 maximum sur les
960 je pense que il y a ouais il y a
peut-être 900 900 ou 930 positions à
jeter à la poubelle mais à mon avis il y
en a quelques-unes qui sont
intéressantes donc j qui
D4 salut je commente un truc mais je
vous explique pendant 3 heur que c'est
de la merde bah c'est juste que je
t'explique pourquoi ça peut pas
fonctionner avec le grand public en fait
c'est pas parce que je le commente que
tu veux que les gens te mentent en fait
tu veux que les gens ils viennent et ils
te ils te disent l'inverse de ce qu'ils
pensent parce que il commente un
truc je crois que c'est pas l'intérêt
des des gens qui donnent leur avis sur
c'est d'avoir la vie réelle de la
personne c'est pas d'avoir quelqu'un qui
qui est payer pour te donner un faux
avis enfin peut-être que tu préfères
99,9 % des influenceurs qui sont payés
par des marques et qui se raconte n pas
à longueur de journée
mais je crois que c'est plus intéressant
d'avoir quelqu'un qui donne son avis
réelle pas biaisé
par par deschecs en
fait juste que je regarde l'événement je
me fais mon propre avis moi-même
dessus
mais je pense que l'idée qu'avait le
viewer tout à l'heure de de jouer de
changer une fois de position tous les
ans je trouve que c'est loin d'être
idiot non mais c'est fou d'être d'en
être arrivé à aimer les gens qui vous
mentent en fait mais je remarque que
c'est de plus en plus comme ça vous êtes
habitué en
fait estce qu'on vous prenne pour des
idiots mais c'est
pas
qui va trash immortal pendant son
Commentar demain mais je commente pas
sur immortal en fait
demain et quand bien même là pour le
coup oui si ça marche pas ça va trche ça
je t'annonce tout de suite que s'il y a
des problèmes de connexion pendant les
finales que je commente ça va trage
instantanément ça peut même quit
d'ailleurs
CD c'est bizarre CD c'est hyper bizarre
j'aurais jou F prendre des
4 une pause parent dans la sélection et
30 positions passables serait Banger je
pense mais bon non ce serait pas Banger
je pense que ce serait quand même naz à
vrai dire mais ce serait mieux mais je
pense ce serait quand même exploser au
sol pour moi le seul truc viable pour
rendre les échecs plus plus populaires
c'est de raccourcir les cadences je l'ai
déjà dit plein de fois je suis convaincu
d'avoir raison mais
après et la barre des Val est fiable
ouais elle a l'air assez fiable on prend
des 4 c'était vraiment bizarre
ok je comprends le coup maintenant mais
il veut donner un pion pour gagner les
cases noir mais
c'est ralentir les cadences j'ai d
ralentir les cadences oui il les
accéléré désolé à force de dire
évidemment
ouis évidemment les
accélérés pour moi de toute façon les
gens pensent que le problème des échecs
c'est la position de départ je suis pas
d'accord pour moi le tu vas faire des
parties de 6h en en 960 je vois pas
pourquoi ce serait plus intéressant que
des parties de 6h sur sur des positions
normal je comprends pas en
fait il va il va se prendre D4 E5 là
l'ordi donne même dame prend à 7 pour
avantage mais oui pourquoi pas aller le
prendre ce pion c'est hyper bizarre ce
qu'il a
fait mais je vois pas pourquoi des
parties de 6h de 960 seraiit plus plus
hpante
ouais je sais
pas ce qui est intéressant pour les
joueurs ne l' pas forcément pour la fan
days ouais mais les joueurs ne jouent
que pour l'argent donc au bout d'un
moment c'est un peu le serpent qui se
mort la queue ils ontvie j en 960 mais
si tu mettais 10000 € de Price pool sur
le tournoi il y aurait personne qui
serait venu
à un moment donné les joueurs ils aiment
pas jouer aux échecs ils aiment l'argent
en fait enfin un moment donné faut faut
être honnête aussi he côté joueur les
joueurs font parfois preuve
d'hypocrisie les joueurs ils aiment
réellement l'argent mais enfin je c'est
pas un mal mais il faut il faut comment
dire il faut dire la vérité
quoi
tu fais le même tournoi tu mets 10000 €
de Price pool tu as personne tu as pas
Carlsen tu as personne qui vient
jouer tu as juste personne qui vient
jouer bon tours l'ordi aime pas mais
c'est un coup logique
hein ben non un peu une life il a il a
pensé que il en a un peu trop voulu avec
ce sacrifice de
pion il lâche pas des TR ben je pense
surt reprend
C1 il va reprendre de la tour il lâche
des TR mais après il rentrera en 7e
rangée
mais oui l'ORD est bien juste d'ame
prend à 7 mais je comprends qu'il l'ai
pas joué
hein
après tu peux dire ça pour toutes les
professions c'est normal de se déplacer
uniquement pour une somme si avait été
Ronaldo Messi on dirait pas ça faut les
respecter les joueurs aussi bah non mais
tout le monde le dit pour Ronaldo et
Messi en
fait Michel de l'ombre tout le monde dit
pour Ronaldo et Messi aussi qui joue
pour l'argent
globalement c'est leur métier à tous
mais juste peut-être qu'ils comprennent
que pour qu'ils puissent gagner autant
d'argent que ce qui gagne il faut que ça
plaise aux gens qui regardent en fait
c'est un métier de
divertissement quoi qu'il en soit que ce
soit le foot ous les échec c'est un
métier spectacle c'est un métier
divertissement même si c'est un sport
donc qui dit divertissement dit que tu
t'adaptes quand même un minimum à ce que
les gens veulent
voir c'est normal les sportif quand tu
es sportif de haut niveau tu fais un
métier de de
divertissement
évidemment tu vas pas leur imposer des
des des des
choses irrespectueuse mais imposer des
cadences rapides ça semble pas par
exemple irrespectueux vu que ils jouent
eux-mêm que en cadence rapide quand il
joue pour
s'amuser fou B2 il veut regag la colonne
c'est plutôt bien joué je
pense donc il joue F
B2
et tour C4 c'est logique
aussi c'est très logique
aussi
ais chbar c'est pas mal j'avais parlé au
gars qui a fait ça si c'est bien eux
je pense c'est eu parce qu'il font ça
sur Bordeaux
ouais
damage
5 ok le problème c'est que la tour est
attaqué par le fou
maintenant et c'est pour ça que ça va
pas du tout parce que tu vas de toute
façon être obligé de faire tour prend C8
mais tu vas avoir perdu un tempo en fait
c'était super mal jouer tour
C4
ouais c'était cata tour C4 en fait
c'était horrible comme coup il a juste
oublié d'amage
5 mais ouais le 960 c'est un jeu qui
demande aussi beaucoup de concentration
c'est un jeu vraiment très très
difficile et on voit forcément plus de
gaffe surtout quand les journées dures
et sont longues comme comme aujourd'hui
avec beaucoup de
parties
mais là ça paraît difficile
maintenant
ouais il fallait vraiment prendre en C8
fallait prendre en A7 mais cétait des
coup vraiment difficile mais là tour C4
ça paraissait bien joué l'idée était
bonne mais en fait c'est juste une
grosse faute
tactique ça passe juste absolument pas
tactiquement en
fait
il faut F3 il y a dame prend
H3 c'est le
problème donc resa qui va s après pas
d'inquiétude hein de toute façon là
c'est pas
éliminatoire pourrait faire 0 sur 7 que
ça changerait pas grand-chose voir même
rien du tout donc c'est
pas pour le moment c'est pas
grave sera plus embêtant s'il perd
dimanche enfin embêtant
pour lui hein
surtout d a bien compris il est parti
pour ce score après je recommande pas
non plus de faire z0ro sur 7 parce que
tu as tu dois être un peu avoir un peu
la confiance au fond des des
chaussettes je recommanderais pas non
plus de de pas remarquer de point du
tout au moins on mettre de TR quand même
pour la
confiance et T prend C8 t prend C8
cavalier F2 ouais mais bon du coup il va
y avoir tour C2 et ça va rentrer de
partout
hein t des de il y aura fou C1 tu peux
pas tu pourras jamais cut en fait la
colonne comme
ça donc non ça su ça su côté
alirea mais je suis pas étonné que
noirbeck il soit fort en 960 parce que
lui il a un peu les les qualités du jeu
il est il il a vraiment les les
meilleures qualités il est bon en
tactique il est très très bon en
magouille ce qui on l'a vu lui a servi
dans sa partie dans la première ronde
contre notre ami
Levon d'ailleur il joue ce que tu dis
mais la tour C2 ça m'a l'air fort on va
voir si si l'ordi valide tour C2
il a vraiment les meilleures qualités
pour pour ce jeu petit jeu tactique bon
magouille il a l'habitude aussi de jouer
des poubelles
ouais c'est tour C de le couain ouais
c'est
logique il a l'habitude de jouer des
poubelles
aussi donc des positions qui sont pas
bien
coordonnées
F F3 il va faire dam 5 maintenant il va
repartir de l'autre
côté
ouais c'est
difficile
il joue fou D4 intermédiaire il veut F
prend F3 dame prend F3 il faut prend H5
faut prend E3 ouais ça a l'air ça a
l'air
fort
ouais ça a l'air fort
ça c'est
terrible
d' pr F3
tour fin et ouais mais les blancs sont
complètement bloqués là il peut plus
bouger il peut plus toucher à rien en
fait
il fait tour 1 mais bon il peut plus
plus toucher à rien là fou prendre des
TR juste on peut pas prendre de la dame
il dame prend F2 on peut pas prendre du
cavalier adame prend G2 B il y a juste
pas de coup quoi il y a juste plus de
coup il y a vraiment juste plus de
coup il va jouer dame 3 je suppose ah
mais dame 3 c'est terrible il a F prend
E4 quelle horreur on peut pas prendre 4
il y aura dame prend F2 donc il sera
obligé d'échanger il aura même pas t
prend 7 il y aura tour tour D1 ah il est
complètement ligoté de partout bon ça va
perdre mais il y a pas
de pas de
souci
terrible
c'est
terrible ça va
perdre il a pas le drit d'abandonner
bon il a peut-être pas envie il essaie
de chercher quelque chose il y a rien à
trouver mais bon il essaie de chercher
une petite chance supplémentaire de
toute
façon maintenant qu'il est là il est
làin donc oui il joue il joue ce ce dame
3 mais cette finale elle est vraiment
horrible
c'est un pion de moins mais c'est c'est
plus qu'un
pion enin c'est plus qu'un pion c'est
que un pion de moin pour le moment mais
la position est c
catastrophique
tiens c'est marrant il y a un il y a un
un redit d'une interview faudraéécouter
sur sur doubbov qui avoue avoir triché
en ligne c'est pas mal les échecs he
toujours toujours au
sommet après c'est pas comme si c'était
une surprise
mais c'est quand même
beau
c'est
magnifique c'est dingue
n'empêche
non mais les gens sont fan parce qu'il
est très
fort
il a déjà dit qu'il allait tricher
contre un autre mec qui trichait pour
vérifier ouais mais ça c'est enin ça
c'est trop facile hein si tu vas faire
un braquage pour vérifier qu'il y a bien
de l'argent dans le dans dans les
convois non tu es un tricheur c'est tout
pu bon mon avis ça se limite pas que à
ça mais
après
il va
abandonner mais c'est exceptionnel en
fait quand on vous dit qu'il y a
beaucoup de tricheurs c'est sur Internet
c'est une
dinguerie dans un moment il gagne aussi
tous les champions ch tour puis s'est
subitement arrêté de les
jouer après on saura jamais hein mais
c'est quand
même
c'est quand même assez
particulierut abandonner là quand même
bientôt la partie est complètement
perdue
et quand c'est B Magnus du coup il dit
plus rien ouais enfin il y a pas que le
cas dou bof pour Magnus mais ouais
Magnus si c'est quelqu'un qui connaît il
dit rien ça le dérange
pas si c'est pas contre
lui
s j'ai vu des gens commenter les deux
premières parties contre carlen dans la
finale de cette semaine en disant qu'il
avait cheat qui alza non al il che pas
al il est il est full cohérent en
vrai Magnus aussi
d'ailleurs ne aussi pour le coup il est
full
cohérent
fait des parties incroyables mais ala en
fait il fait des parties incroyables
mais il fait aussi de de de sacré boous
hein de temps en
temps
il Reza qui se bat comme il
peut est-ce que est-ce que Ding ouais
ding ding c'est dur et les autres
parties ah Levan il a perdu en quatre
coups ah Levan il a perdu en 6 coups
qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ah ça l'a saoulé il a abandonné
mais c'est exceptionnel ça
il y a tellement pas d'en jeu qu'il
essaie même pas de se défendre il a
vraiment abandonné là gen c'est pas du
troll
ouais c'est réel ah ouais il c'est à ce
point là en
fait c'est R à ce point là non il a joué
il a eu 19 coups
ok c'est un bug je me disais quand même
c'était c'était trop de
Raf on va retourner sur
alirea donc qui est toujours aussi foutu
mais il joue je sais pas pourquoi il
joue mais il
joue
terrible
de faire tram s'il abandonne pas ouais
je sais vraiment pas pourquoi il
abandonne pas attendez il y a pas c 5
échecs
là
ah ro prend F4 qui prend B3 il y a tour
A2 et puis on prend B3 ok
ok
ok B go ça a
gagné Magnus ça a gagné reste quoi
d'autre
après ah eu la partie a buggé aussi
c'est ça parce qu'ils sont pas asse de
coup ah voilà ils en sont
là Ker qui est peut-être pas mal on va
attendre bon c'est firouja qui a
abandonné on va aller voir Ker pour la
dernière partie de cette magnifique
journée d'échec
évidemment ça
joue ouais c'est mieux pour les blancs
ça ça semble le pion D4 est
condamné mond en 04 ouais mais après
c'est pas des échecs là attention c'est
pas tout à fait le même
jeu
c'est pas tout à fait le même
jeu tu enfin bah c'est du 960 c'est pas
des échecs classiques donc c'est pas la
même
chose
c'est pas la même
chose on a encore cette magnifique
partie à suivre jusqu'au
bout il a aucune casuse ser cool de
mettre le calier
noir après le roi blanc est un peu
faible aussi
hein si le cavalier atteint la case C5
il sera peut-être pas si mal
je ah ouais
complètement ça assez magnifique je suis
déçu qu'il y a pas une 5è partie là
derrière ça aurait pu me mettre très
bien surtout il y en a que trois deain
c'est pas de
bol c'est juste que c'est 5 tu V
difficilement y avoir
accès c'est plus ça le
problème vivement les long bah les
longues il y en a que une par jour donc
il vaut mieux quatre rapides que une
longue pour
moi
tour B7 dame a 6 il va mettre la tour en
is mais il peut envoyer le pion d après
c'est bien joué ce dame
A6 qui fait tour D7 mais ah s'il échange
il veut gagner la tour pas CLA la tour
F8 qui sera enfermé on sa s vont changer
ah ouais il change de position à toutes
les parties au moins c'est parfait au
moins on voit beaucoup de positions
différentes c'est d'autant plus
intéressant
là c'est
7 c'est bien joué pens dam 6 un bon coup
il a joué tempo mais il a oublié ça
Fabiano il avait deux sur 3 jusqu'à
maintenant
mais notre ami Ding va terminer dernier
he très probablement à moins qu'il batte
Aronian c'est un bon entraement pour les
candidats pour ce challenge 2024
non sert quasiment à rien en faitin pour
l'entraînement ça lui fait jouer
quelques parties sans avoir à dévoiler
d'ouverture il prend un énorme chèque
probablement
donc donc c'est tant
mieux le price pool c'est 200000 dollars
et il y a il y a que H joueurs donc dans
tous les cas c'est bien puis c'est TR
tout frais payé dans un hôtel très très
luxueux et puis a souvent après on peut
pas savoir c'est pas dévoilé mais il y a
très souvent des starting fee importants
alors sûrement pour Carlsen ça c'est
évident mais j'imagine que pour tout le
monde il y a quelque
chose starting fi qui parfois peuvent
être même plus conséquent que que le
premier prix du tournoi ça ça peut même
arriver des des choses comme
ça starting fee c'est c'est de l'argent
qui t''est payé juste enfin plutôt à PIR
un FEI juste pour venir en fait c'est
quelque chose donc qui est pas dévoilé
dans le price pool mais c'est c'est de
l'argent qui est donné aux joueurs
euh juste pour leur
présence
alors là il faut trouver quoi t prends
D8 dame prend D8 et dame D2 juste tout
bêtement le truc le plus simple suivi de
dame prend
des4 mais bon avec peu de temps plus
rien n'est simple il joue dame F4 qui
est vraiment logique alors là attention
cavalier D6 ah maintenant il qui
D6 parce qu'il aura peut-être un dame un
échec qui va
tomber sur notre ami Vincent
CER
il réfléchit Carana cavaler D6 c'est pas
simple à trouver
mais il peut l'avoir plus que 23
secondes pour
lui il fait
F6 si on prend F6
tempo il va jouer t prend je
pense prend F6 dam
H6 prend D7 cavalier prend a tout qui va
tomber ça devrait win pour
Ker fabil là qui a un peu explosé du
coup il prend des7 en premier mais ça va
reprendre en
D7
et maintenant il va jouer tour F7 ouais
le coup
logique peut-être il peut jouer dame non
pas dame 5 ah le cou qui gag c'est Dame
B8 dur à trouver dame B8 mais il peut
l'avoir quand même a non pas si dur dame
B8 d B8 il peut l'avoir ouais je pense
qu'il l'a
ouis il l'a il a il a et oui parce que d
prend8 d prend
D7
pas un coup simple mais trouver les
victoires de Vincent CER donc qui arrive
à à 3 points et demi hein Vincent CER
magnifique on va voir un peu le les prix
vu que vous m'avez
demandé ça c'est la
dotation donc peut-être que pour le
ranking après il reprennent si tu perds
en quart de finale et que tu as fini 6e
ou 7e peut-être que c'est ton ranking
euh dans le tourno rapide qui rejoue
quoi pour la kayas à la fin c'est
peut-être ça en fait
l'enjeu et le lineup et le lineup voilà
vous avez les
joueurs et donc demain on aura encore
les
rapides et donc voilà on va s'arrêter
là-dessus merci à tous d'avoir suivi on
sera de retour bien évidemment demain
donc pour suivre la suite du tournoi
rapide et on se retrouvera et on se
retrouve donc demain vers 1